e
okay uh open up the public hearing on
House Bill
good morning representative
Amman good morning good morning to the
the best looking Committee in the State
House Commerce
Committee so for the record my name is
Keith Ammon Hillsboro District 42 New
Boston not Vernon and line
bro uh two disclaimers I do own digital
assets and I'm also the chair of the New
Hampshire blockchain Council it's an all
volunteer nonprofit
so having said that the the next two
bills are similar and
related uh this first one house bill uh
310 has to do with uh stable
tokens and tokenize real world
assets it would set up a study
commission to develop a framework a
legal framework for the state around
issuers of stable tokens and in
tokenized real world
assets so a stable
token is a digital token represented on
the blockchain it's backed by US Dollars
treasuries and basically it pegs its
value to the US
dollar uh a tokenized real world asset
is very similar the asset backing it
could be gold it could be real estate it
could be
artwork um anything value could back a
tokenized could be tokenized so the
tokenization represents ownership it's
sort of like a receipt for ownership and
the value is it trades on the blockchain
an open public Ledger we've talked about
these things before um a blockchain is
basically
infrastructure a blockchain is like the
electric grid it's like the Internet
it's like roads and bridges it's
infrastructure it's a way to communicate
value value across the internet uh
across space and time and across borders
so if you tokenize a real world asset
put it on the blockchain that ownership
can be traded 247 globally in in a
frictionless way in an easy way to
validate that you have an asset uh you
have ownership of an
asset the reason why a study commission
is is the right thing at the right time
is because there are moving pieces on
the chessboard there are federal
legislation
uh Senators Lumis and Gill brand have a
bill it's called the uh I think it's
called the
payment the payment stable stable coin
act uh and that bill has been worked on
since earlier 2024 so we want to see how
the federal how it plays out at the
federal
level um one interesting thing the state
of Wyoming has a commission it's called
the stable token commission and it's not
a study commission it's a commission to
enact a stable token the state of
Wyoming is going to issue a US dollar
backed token stable coin uh on on
multiple
blockchains uh and they're going to do
it with the sovereignty of the state of
Wyoming so that's kind of an interesting
concept that's not what we're talking
about here this would be the private
sector doing
it the the chair of the Wyoming stable
token commission is the governor of the
interesting yeah Mr chair you're rolling
impressive what is his name again the
governor of Wyoming yes
yeah what is his name didn't he run for
president and then he that's North
Dakota I think you're thinking veto the
uh the other token leg type legislation
maybe that was Christy gnome of South
Dakota that you're think that's Christy
yeah but was other starts with the B
what's last name uh I think bergam
you're thinking that's a different state
yeah
okay so so anyway there's there's some
moving there's some moving uh parts that
would make sense to have a study
commission and the the reason is the the
state has uh its own sovereignty and uh
you know we can do things at a state
level
what a stable token uh
legislation regulatory regime would look
like is ensuring that an issuer of a
token of an asset back
token uh honestly represents the amount
of assets they have in
custody um so for instance if I had a
Bor of gold and I tokenized it a
dishonest actor would say I'm going to
sell 10 tokens for my one bar of gold
and so you're you're representing the
fact that that ownership represents that
bar of gold you see what I mean so you
would have auditing this is just you
know thinking of it through you'd have
auditing uh of the assets and then you'd
have something called proof of reserves
on the blockchain where you would look
at the blockchain and say these units
add up to the assets you know that an
independent auditor uh you know uh said
that you know signed off on you having
those
so anyway that's uh just rambling off
the top of my head but I have some
people behind me I think that would talk
more about
it okay so if I get this straight we're
talking about uh an actual commodity
because it's always been my issue with
digitals
that whatever the 39 digigit number is
not a commodity to me it's just a piece
of paper right so in this case there is
an underlying value there is an
underlying asset right and that
basically you're going to
offer stock ownership of that item yeah
and you're using this the crypto
platform as the way to do it right and
so the predictions of this Market the
size of this Market is something like 10
trillion do it's like a it's potentially
a very large market and financial uh
companies Banks Fidelity bny melon
they're all looking into tokenization of
real world assets and uh it's something
that the state I think should get ahead
of so with I'll take any
questions okay repres M thank you so I'm
a little confused what what is really
the purpose or reason for this and then
secondly uh why do we need
it so uh second question first this is
getting ahead of where the financial
markets are going so this is uh being a
step ahead of uh future Innovation so
that's why we need it um we want to
position our state ahead of the pack
right
um why we need it so whenever you deal
with just the virtual world when it's
just a virtual token there's no physical
real world thing behind it then you you
wouldn't need this but the fact that
we're trying the fact that you need to
marry uh tokenization with a a real
asset in the real world then you need a
regulatory framework to make sure that
there aren't bad actors issuing tokens
that you know misrepresenting the
value does that make sense okay uh I did
represent Spears next and then I'll come
side I kind of like the idea off the top
of my head but I have a contact in the
FBI and they said that both Wyoming and
North Dakota are the largest Clearing
Houses for money laundering in the state
and they do it with stablecoin so you
have't who is your Source what's his
name I've got it written H Haskins I
think is his last name but I can get the
details and give you that okay uh and
but and I have also read that in other
places so the the question is now
Wyoming and and North Dakota have set
themselves up specifically for that in
some
ways whether you want to believe that or
not you can do the research or I can
show you my research and I don't have a
problem if we do it and we just make
sure we're not going to be in the money
laundering business and so so that's a a
thing I'm concerned about when we set up
this commission I just want to make sure
that we're not going to be in the money
laundering business or the income tax
Invasion
believe okay I said I go back to the
next slide so I'll be back over to you
okay okay represent
Gibs thank you Mr chairman um sorry
uh is there any advantage to having such
regulations done at the state level
rather than at the federal level which
would make them standardized
Nationwide well so the the federal level
has its domain and the states have their
domain and we were elected to represent
the states uh Powers right so that's
what we would be we would be protecting
uh in this framework so like as I said
there is some legislation pending at the
federal level but that doesn't
necessarily block States from doing
their own thing to to be to being like
the you know the the gold standard of
tokenized real world assets that if
you're following the rules of New
Hampshire people can trust that your
asset is fully backed and compliant with
the with the regime of the state and so
I guess there you know yes at the
federal level and also yes at the state
level okay uh represent
churis so um thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question so the
question is that is this a different
token than Bitcoin you're proposing or
is it tokenizing all the assets
piggybacking on bitcoin or or some some
some Bitcoin related
stuff
um
so Bitcoin has its own network and you
can there's there's a protocol called
tap rot where you can issue tokens on
the Block on the Bitcoin blockchain but
this would be blockchain
agnostic uh you you know an issuer could
potentially issue tokens on you know
Bitcoin ethereum salana Avalanche all
these top level blockchains and they can
even bridge between them so it' be
blockchain agnostic I think the way that
I'm conceiving this does that make sense
so it could be Bitcoin but also others
it's about storing the representation of
ownership on a blockchain
inquire so so are you proposing some
other
standardized Co I mean coin so if if you
read the bill you'll see the the
position of the commission the the the
duties of the commission is to establish
this it's sort of to craft legislation
for the future does that make sense
thank
you okay uh um I thought I I thought he
of him too okay fine representative
buroughs for the question thanks for
taking my question um here's my concern
I mean sometimes we have a commission
and to be very I guess blunt about it
sometimes they're stacked in favor of a
certain wanting a certain outcome and um
and I'm not saying this is going to be
this way but it's going to be three
members of the House of rep appointed by
the speaker two members of the Senate
appointed by the Senate President and
the governor appoints some of these
other people what assurances do we have
that this commission will be balanced so
that you know we can get we can really
un get a real good understanding of the
risks and the
benefits yeah I mean it's a great
question every commission kind of faces
that I'm open like I think this is an
average bill I'm open open to improving
the bill um I think coming behind me
we're going to see uh someone talking
about the ulc uniform law commission I
think maybe UC well the ulc creates the
UCC
right um so I think you know adding that
position uh adding a position like that
to balance it out I think would be a
good
idea okay representa
Gibbs uh thank you Mr chairman uh this
is actually a follow-up question um if
the federal government uh were to enact
a law regulating um stable coins and
tokenized assets um isn't it possible
that that would occupy the field and
block State
regulation uh not completely I think
it'll set some parameters on what state
regulation could be but you know as you
know our state has its own trust laws
that are different from other states we
have state chartered banks that are
different from other states like there
there still there will still be uh an
area for State involvement i' just like
to to add a lot of the bills that we
passed blockchain related have come out
of commissions like it's a pretty normal
thing it's it's a complicated subject so
it makes sense to have experts study it
and propose legislation so that's why
I'm going with this
approach so even if the feds did come
out with their own plan it would be up
to whoever choose to um uh have this
Capital item that they're capitalizing
and having the using the blockchain
system to decide which set of statutes
which laws they want to be under do they
want to be State chartered under the
state law or would they want to be on
federal federal
law okay
represent uh thank you chairman for
taking my call uh my question is uh how
this is going to benefit the New
Hampshire resident because if you have
done any kind of a demographics how many
percentage of the resident will get
benefit out of it and what is the risk
uh I think one risk is not having a
framework for regulating it and just
letting letting it be the wild west at
the state level right I mean the there's
a downside to not doing it I think um
you know how many of our residents own
stocks and bonds municipal bonds or you
know it this is this is projected by
people smarter than me to uh
become uh more and more of the economy
so it would allow our residents to feel
comfortable that a token issued by the
state of New Hampshire won isn't going
to cheat them right but it actually
represents the value that it reports to
so that would be you know a benefit to
an increasing segment of society may I
ask a followup question further question
uh have you done any kind of research
with the New Hampshire resident about
the impact on the Bitcoin or what they
think about it before for presenting the
bill or something like that was there
any
done uh so the idea for this bill came
out of the the governor's crypto
Commission in 2022 so the governor
issued an order we had a year-long
commission and this this idea wasn't in
the report but it was part of the
discussions around you know the I think
the clarification is needed
here we're we're not talking about going
into the Bitcoin or the stablecoin
business right we're setting up a
commission to decide what rules we
should have should someone else want to
start up one in New Hampshire we're not
going in the business with this no
that's we're setting up an environment I
would say represent salvi that uh what
this Comm committee has been very
aggressive in doing is always trying to
stay on the front lines of being uh have
as many different methodologies of
investing um and for instance our trust
laws um our family trust laws we've
always been out on the Forefront of
carrying these now to say is well how
many people are really going to be able
to take advantage of it or how much is
it a benefit um I would say is more than
anything else we're trying to be a
magnet we're trying to attract people to
in to come to us to move to New
Hampshire or invest in New Hampshire and
and invest these prod and take advantage
of these products is it dangerous for
the state to do it no because at the end
of the day if the product fails or
whatever they're doing the business
fails that's no skin it doesn't affect
us as New Hampshire it might say is oh
well New Hampshire shouldn't have
shouldn't have created that opportunity
you could always argue said the
Hampshire you know what's the matter
with you guys you know we're always
trying to do all this state-ofthe-art
Cutting Edge you know new just kind of
financial transactions but I would say
over the history um in terms of how one
of the reasons why trust law how comes
to you was coming to this committee
rather Judiciary is because um I I was
the sponsor of the of uniform trust code
and changing the uniform trust code and
I was the sponsor of getting of um of
the of I'm spacing out of the moment but
it was related to uh that the fact that
trust had to expire and we got I
sponsored that legislation so so the
long run we're always trying to be on
Cutting Edge to have all these new
interesting new methodologies of of
investing out there uh we did last year
we did digital uh digital assets so so
we're we're always doing this it it
doesn't hurt the state we always have
the uh the Secretary of State's office
who does Securities and has they're
always inv monitoring it they're always
involved they're certainly will have a
seat at the table of this commission and
they ensure that there is no potential
exposure to the state but that at the
same time uh we we are always excited
about trying to take on new new things
that are Cutting Edge okay chairman just
may I ask a followup question to you
certainly because uh I just wanted to be
clear I'm representing my ward so any of
the constituents is asking me why we are
getting into why we're considering a
commission for a digital asset what is
the answer I should give because I
didn't get the answer we we should
regulate it we should regulate it that's
the answer there is no downside and what
you can say to your constituents is this
is a uh that New Hampshire is is having
another
opportunity to have an investment
vehicle and maybe it's not affecting
them I mean I but I I I would say is
there a lot of people who have been
moving to New Hampshire certainly since
Co and and prior to that who moving to
Hampshire because we're Innovative with
these different kinds of methodologies
of investment oh okay thank you I go
ahead okay representative Herbert
Herbert
um there's I think I've read that the
absolute total value of
uh the United States is about
$226 trillion
dollar now my question is uh had are we
going to
attach um the those assets
as a available to uh um Bitcoin or any
stable coin or uh as as a legitimate um
representation of the dollar which is um
the the world's Reserve yeah um I'm I'm
having a difficult time trying to figure
out how the
connections um how are you going to
marry uh with the uh the concepts of
digital
assets I just don't understand and and
is and my and my follow on question
is does the federal government have
to uh
endorse uh whatever we do because the
dollar is a worldwide currency I know
you're you have you're worried about the
dollar losing its Reserve status and I
am too because that would affect all of
our you know standard of living we we
our money would become worthless right
the eighth largest purchaser of us
treasuries is a company called tether
they issue US dollar back stable coins
they've recently moved to El Salvador as
their for with their headquarters
because El Salvador's friendly with this
it but it's it's the eightth largest
purchaser of us treasuries and they
tokenize the US dollar and it it trades
all 247 all around the world and it it
makes the dollar uh penetrate markets
that it previously couldn't it can
penetrate a market where people just
have cell phones they don't need a bank
to you know have an account with the
bank so the US dollar can penetrate
further around the world because it's
tokenized and that will uh encourage
demand for the dollar like into the
foreseeable future so if you're worried
about the dollar tokenizing the dollar
is a positive um can I follow on I I
don't I haven't gotten a um the answer
I'm the question I'm asking is yes in a
legal
framework the dollar is the United
States currency correct it is used it it
has functionally U become the reserve
currency for the world and now uh my
concern is that someone is going to come
along and say oh I have this tokenized
digital real world what ever and and um
we have absolutely no idea what the
ramifications are going to be unless at
least we should have the the the um
appropriate body which would be the
United States and Congress to say okay
fine I'm satisfied you the dollar is
just like the
tokenized uh currency that you're you're
you're trying to that Mr representative
Herbert I would totally believe
that I'm I'm I'm just wondering I for
question if if the answer you're looking
for is has this have the potential of
undermining the dollar and I would say
is that uh I cannot see that because I'm
looking at this as simply that the item
is like think of it as a corporation as
an entity and it's selling stock and the
stock
that is the stock is being traded as a
token yeah and keep it as simple as that
that's what this bill does that's
perfect
Al okay all right repres spe you
mentioned you mentioned something very
quickly in passing and I'm not sure I
understood what you meant by it you said
that let's say we had a gold bar and
somebody sold 10 tokens against the gold
bar when it was only supposed to be one
and then you said this way the the state
of New Hampshire would ensure that it it
it was valid now I I do a little bit of
gold trading yeah that was just an
example of a an asset that's in the real
world right it could be it could be a
picture I don't care what it is
right are we saying that the state is
going to
[Music]
guarantee let's say it is gold because
it's very easy to to represent gold
right or even land are we saying that if
some business sets up a a stable coin
kind of thing mhm and they followed all
of our laws and everything and how we
come up with it does that
mean that the state of New Hampshire is
going to guarantee that in fact by
weight because that's how gold is done
it's by weight to some number of
milligrams or grams or whatever it is
that that gold is physically
there uh I mean that's that could be
quite this would be up to the the
commission to decide but the way I'm
picturing it and some other states are
are you know pursuing it is the the
state would require that if you're going
to issue a token backed by an asset that
you have to have regular audits done by
right so the audits have to be done
quarterly monthly whatever whatever we
set up and then the state would verify
that in fact the aits were done the
state would maybe license or you know
provide a you permission to to continue
your operation as long as you're
auditing on the physical the real world
side and you're doing something called
proof of reserves on the token side
because the blockchain is open you can
sum up where you know all the token
amounts and make sure that they match in
in the banking world it's called
rehypothecation so when you put money in
the bank they lend out 90% of it sure
whatever right so you know
there that's why I run on the bank is a
problem the bank doesn't have all the
money the money's other places right so
that's called rehypothecation in this
situation we wouldn't want that we would
want one one toone backing and make sure
that people aren't misrepresenting that
your token is actual ownership over a
set asset follow on it's just a follow
so what I'm understanding is I just want
to make it clear that we're we're not in
the business of weighing these assets
and running out the fields and making
sure the land is exactly what they said
we're just going to look at the auditing
Trail and make sure that auditing Trail
exists and it's valid exactly we would
set up the guidelines in which we would
allow that Arthur Anderson that so just
like we have the uh when it comes to the
stock market you know a stock a publicly
traded stock is still is regulated there
is an oversight in terms of they have to
have audited financials and they have to
document their assets and have to do
reports stock reports and stuff like
that but at the end of the day the
company could get wiped out oh yeah okay
and so that's the same thing with these
you really just think of these entities
is that you're all you're doing is you
are uh creating whatever that whatever
the asset is you're creating a company
around it yeah and that company has is
thatat to how to have have ownership of
it is based upon U tokens rather than
stock issues I I I understood all that I
just didn't want us to be in the
business of auditing and then being held
responsible no no we would set up the
requirements that they would have to but
at the end of the day John Hunt's rule
of lure will probably kick in of what
John Hunt's rule of lure why why do we
create licenses so can so we can take
them away yes okay and maybe insurance
is part of the requirement that we said
right maybe require in terms of in you
would normally would you say is who is
going to be responsible um whether it's
a federal state but again you're
creating a the structure is under the
state law so in terms of our Securities
yes our Securities division uh is
ensures that the company that's
Incorporated in New Hampshire lives up
to it um insurance is an exact
interesting because insurance that there
is no federal insurance
regulations um and in each state
individual state that the insurance
company is domiciled in that State's
insurance department is their regulator
who regularly goes in and audits their
numbers and most importantly is solvency
go in there and make sure that that
they're really solvent so they got to
prove the
assets and there was a court case uh
where somebody a famous um uh called
Bitcoin crash was because the person uh
was using his tokens and he was
inventing a number of what he said the
tokens were worth but he had no
structure there nothing behind to prove
that those tokens were really worth
anything and so and and and he he went
to jail so right uh so like I say this
is not this is not
totally unbelievable but it's it's a
good idea that the state of New
Hampshire um is to again to stay out in
front of these new Concepts and new and
yeah it's it's like it's like inviting a
corporation to come to New Hampshire we
want them to incorporate in New
Hampshire we don't want them to all go
to Delaware okay we got to stop that you
know go to
well it was North Dakota we don't want
them to go to we don't want to go to but
I always thought North Dakota was one of
the other competitors in Delaware But
but so any
rate um this is a would you believe um
not really question I would like to
recommend to people on this committee I
think there are a lot of us who really
don't have a solid understanding about
Bitcoins and stable coins and all that
and there's there's really good
information on YouTube there's 98
Bitcoin it's a it's an educational um
videos you can watch and I I would
highly recommend it so all of us are
really up to
speed and and certainly represent Ammon
as a as a resource make sure you send
out that link to all the members okay so
Bitcoin it's a it's an amazing invention
and uh it's you know it's it's finding
its way into lots of aspects of society
it's been running non-stop for 16 years
like this is it seems like a new thing
but it's been running non-stop for 16
years and it's you know president
presidential candidates are talking
about it it's uh you know interesting
representative melier and represent um
nobody has said this explicitly but it
seems to me that this is nothing more
than another security that would be
regulated on the state basis and the
national basis by the security Exchange
Commission and and you'd have to this
case it's going to be State yeah it
would be a state well yeah say
exactly an you're it's more like a
commodity than a than a company right so
like a gold bar doesn't have like a
profit and loss you know statements it's
it's just a a commodity and so a real
world asset would be like land is not a
security right it's but but I can
securitize land I can securitize
anything and again unless I'm totally
out of it this has got to be a security
it is okay isn't that sense okay
represent Gibbs thank
you and thank you represent
Amon for um clarifying some of this uh
for us um and just for
clarity um one of the elements of the
regulation if such a regulation came
forward um would be guardrails against
the state um having any risk of being
held responsible if there were
fraud I think yeah I I agree with that
the state has uh you know it's pretty
much
it doesn't have much liability you know
if the state's not engaged in the
business it wouldn't have liability
that's the way I would see it but I I
agree that should be a
consideration okay represent
shes thank you uh taking a question so
would you
believe
that we just heard about stock and secur
securitization a stock has value based
on the profit the company either makes
or the profit is going to make so there
is certain backing behind the value of
the stock yeah similarly a currency for
example dollar or any any currency is
based on the GDP of the country so
everything is backed by the
real asset which is measured in terms of
tangible assets the demand for the asset
the question is that how do you the what
you proposing creating a
digital asset and combining all
the you know assets like go gold or
whatever all the assets tag this along
this proposed asset I proposed token how
do you determine the value of those
underlying uh asset that you're going to
bring through this token what what
should be the so the market does that
the market determines the value as long
as the token represents the actual share
or portion of the asset as long as that
link is maintained then the market will
determine the value of the token does
that make sense what would no well let
say to you ises be careful when we J
about the stock mark because they they
say that the stock market reflects not
the current size of the company the it
it reflects what people think it's going
to be in the future you're you're
betting on their future with that stock
I mentioned that yeah and but that that
the reality is that um all they could do
they could the next day they could or
they they could be hit with a major
lawsuit you know and and throws the
company into bankruptcy even though the
the fundamental assets were all there
but that because they picked up that
liability all of a sudden it's but but
those are all
measurable uh all those those parameters
all measurable based on that that the
stock is determined or the currency is
determined what I mean I'm I'm having to
understand how are you going to measure
the
value here's what I want to do now okay
is that I think we all pretty much have
an idea what the proposal is yeah we
will take this up in our subcommittee
okay and we can certainly thrash it out
in the subcommittee uh and and but I
would say to everybody remind this is
just a commission doesn't mean we're
we're okaying it right we're just
creating a commission to see if it is
possible to do something like this and
what would be the parameters and what
would be the things that it need to have
who would theer be participate in that
thank okay all right thank you very much
chair's calls on uh uh the banking the
sakim good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Seth Zaraki I'm
the general counsel at the New Hampshire
banking Department um the banking
department has no objection to this bill
or to the establishment of uh the
commission on stable coin um if this
bill does become law uh we would welcome
the opportunity to participate on the
commission uh the department doesn't
have any other formal testimony today
but um I'd be happy to feel any
questions that you may have I have a
question oh my God okay yes it's it's
it's just a it's just a for me the
fundamental question
is um are we talking about a
currency or a
commodity uh what is what is I would
like to see a legal answer
determining where that uh this idea of a
a
tokenization uh real
world fake I don't you know I don't know
how to describe it I I'm worried about
our currency and I don't want it to be
attached
to something I think is quite
volatile and and not well established
okay stick to your question you're
worried about how would this have an
impact on our currency I would like to
see an answer to this question from that
but you just repeated yourself twice I
just want to say you got your question
stated do you understand I'm asking I
understand exactly your question thank
you yeah so that's a good question
representative I think Regulators at the
federal level who who uh you know
regulate and handle the US currency
certainly have voiced concerns about
that with respect to stable coin and US
dollar back stable coin um and I think
that's one of the things that the
commission would would look at on this
whether stable coin is a commodity a
currency a security um that would
require the input of Securities
Regulators Commodities Regulators which
I am I am not um what I can say is the
current regulatory framework um was not
drafted with stable coin in mind and
that leads to uncertainty um on the very
questions that you are asking um and
it's generally agreed that the United
States would benefit um from better
stable coin policy at both the state and
federal level and I think that's ex
exactly what this uh commission appears
to be attended to intended to look at I
want to know if it's a currency or not
it is not a currency all right it is not
a currency we've already been over this
multiple times it is not currency
okay thank you very much thank you uh
Charles
commission thank
you thank you chair H Vice chair
producer members of the committee my
name is Charles
money I moved to New Hampshire several
years ago a few years ago from the
University of Pennsylvania after I
retired and uh last year I was appointed
by Governor sonunu as a commissioner on
uniform state laws uh for New
Hampshire uh Mike you have to move close
to yeah is that better sorry I'm very
sorry uh I was appointed late last year
by the governor as a commissioner on
uniform state laws for New
Hampshire uh all 50 states have such
commissioners uh many have more than one
um and they come up with uniform laws
that we present to the states and hope
the states enact them and several very
fundamental laws in New Hampshire come
out of this uniform state law process
including the Uniform Commercial Code
Uniform Partnership Act uniform gift to
miners act there's a huge list of things
New Hampshire has uh has
adopted
uh although HB
310 is not a uniform law that came out
of this uh process uh it would be an
excellent complement I believe to the
new article 12 of the UCC which New
Hampshire adopted a couple of years
ago
uh article 12 deals with the digital
assets the electronic record but one
thing it did not does not and could not
deal with is any connection between that
digital asset and a real world
asset uh because that would involve the
law of goods of intangibles of
intellectual property of real estate of
every kind of property and so other law
would govern that and how it's linked
and as representative
em indicated that the core idea here uh
is that uh a digital asset can be linked
to a real W asset so that when you
acquire on the internet the digital
asset it carries with it the
ownership of the real world
asset one of the problems of course is
if I were to invest in such a digital
asset hoping it carried with it a gold
bar for example or anything
else how do I know it's there do do I
have a property interest in that
underlying asset or do I just have a
promise like a demand deposit from a
bank a promise that if you ask me I'll
give it to you but that's unsecured
promise uh these are issues that involve
consumer protection
disclosure uh and the the the core
elements of what what regulation of of
investing has to do uh so I think this
would very well complement uh what we
have in article 12 I listened carefully
to the excellent questions from the
members of the committee and if I
understand this correctly I think this
commission would be charged with
answering those questions they're not
questions that this bill would would
answer but the commission would be
interested in protecting the rights of
investors in New Hampshire and the
rights of people who want to form
businesses the such as with these uh uh
tokens uh in New Hampshire in the long
run it may well be that there will be
Federal Regulation of these
assets uh it may or may not be good and
we may or may not like it but there will
normally be some room for State
regulation but more
importantly right now we're not very
close to having a very thorough Federal
Regulation of these assets uh I hope
they make more progress in the next few
years than we have in the past few years
but you know state law is a laboratory
it's an incubator it's a place where
people try things experiment with the
regulation experiment with the private
law the property laws and and see
whether it works or not so I think this
is a a wonderful thing for New Hampshire
to be uh to be doing regardless of what
happens on the federal level uh you can
look at the example of uh California and
see there are many federal regulations
which California has choosen chosen to
go further uh in terms of protecting uh
uh people that's also an area that New
Hampshire might uh uh uh considered so
uh I think the questions are all good I
hope this commission could answer them
in a in a good way and uh uh I would
certainly support it so thank you for
your time I'm happy to answer any
questions you might
have oh represent spear this is just
asking your opinion and based on the
had a stable coin that is based on the
US dollar which there are some already
out
there I could see a situation in which
the US dollar becomes spread more
prevalent than it even is based on these
stat stable coins that is more people
might end up having access to those
dollars via the stable coins than what
they actually have
now is that something that could be
envisioned yes I think I think it is uh
just like investing in mutual funds
which are very different here because
those are securities allows investors
access to things they otherwise might
not have easy uh easy act to asess to
but we think of a stable coin as being
pegged to the dollar but when you look
at the ones that exist and have existed
there's a great variety some of them
work some of them don't some of them
involve substantial risk others don't
and this is exactly the kind of thing I
think the commission would look into
what what rules do we want to set down
for people who say if you buy this stle
toin you have rights in a
dollar uh those are questions to be
responsive Ro thank you very much thank
you uh chair we call on make the right
good morning my name is Michael Yamauchi
uh I live in Bedford New Hampshire and
with my family and um my background is
just a entrepreneur and
investor I used to own internet
companies and I saw the digital age
blossom in 1994 currently I'm an
investor in in real estate in both San
Francisco and New
Hampshire and in the last four or five
years this asset called crypto has
caught my attention and I want to let
you know why everything that can be
digitized and it can be uh everything
that you own can be digitized and it can
be proved that you uh uh it can be
proven instantly and so we need the
legal boundaries if we're going to do
this uh if we're going to you take
advantage of this
technology and this is why I support uh
hp310 um I'll give you two quick
examples
I received a tax refund check a
deposited in a local Bank in
Bedford not that long ago and they told
me that I have to they have to put it on
hold for uh 10 business days um I didn't
I didn't really need the check but
there's a lot of people that do and 10
business days is two weeks I mean why
would a why do we need to hold something
for 10 weeks uh um because a check has
you know the a check has the proof of
work on there it has the bank account
it's got the it's got the uh uh the the
the the account numbers the bank name
and everything uh and and you it should
be able to be proved instantly but it
can't it takes two weeks because even if
they got the money they want to hold on
to the check until so anyways you know
what I'm saying and and so there's a lot
of work to be improved there also
purchasing real estate closing closing
and selling real estate can be
simplified much more efficiently people
who own time shares uh can finally sell
them if you if uh in an easy manner
where now if you own a time share you
probably have to give it back I mean I
have a friend who just gave back two
time shares because you know they're not
going to be able to sell it uh title
companies can verify titles easily and
tenant leases can be placed on a
blockchain for example to eliminate fake
leases that squatters can use
to illegally take over the property so
the benefits are endless and we are just
at the
beginning like it's 1994 in the internet
age so uh in closing I'd like uh uh from
cashing checks to high value
transactions uh in any
industry a regulatory framework for
crypto will benefit us
immensely so if you have any questions
if not that's
ahead with your background um is is
interesting um I'm I'm what I Stumble
over is the is the fact that
um Can the dollar uh be uh so um used in
that fashion I mean if it's a digital if
it's a digital
Network um I almost have no problem just
saying it's dollars I don't understand
why we have to say it's crypto or
Bitcoin or some other thing uh you know
uh so the advantages you you ticked off
to me I I think are um uh distributional
they're part of a process a digital
process that may be more
sophisticated but my my question to you
is why can't it be done for the dollar
because the dollar doesn't change in
value i i i the dollar is the dollar I
just might State my opinion in terms of
the dollar you want to protect the
dollar right uh
um in my opinion all you have to do is
just
legislate uh that things like tether or
you know altcoins uh uh um stable coins
are uh a certain amount invested in uh
uh um invested in the US dollar whatever
you hold in cash you invest it in the
treasuries you know or or something like
that and you're backing the dollar
instantly right right there and every
nation will use uh I don't want to speak
for the banking industry or anything but
every nation is going to use their own
currency but when you when you do it in
the US in the US you can you can set a
certain amount in in of uh of purchases
that you're holding in cash just in
treasuries that they're going to make
money and and uh you know I think it's a
fantastic way to back up the dollar it's
it's actually I used to think of it uh
uh your way uh representative Herbert
but uh I think it actually is going to
benefit the dollar rather than hurt it
right now you're going to get a lot more
opinion close but not
salie if you're still willing to take a
question
sorry now you need to have your mic on y
thank you for taking my
chairman uh my question is
basically see now when I sell the real
estate I get the check in my bank okay
everybody's comfortable with that if I'm
going to get the Bitcoin
okay I don't know don't even know as of
now or I cannot visualize how to
what the value will be and how I can
sell it and what's there in the market
okay as a usual normal investor I'm an
entrepreneur I know it very well I
understand the process I'm not against
the Bitcoin but things are not clear to
me I don't know how things will be clear
to my constituents or my voters
that I don't know Banks also saying that
they are going to support it state is
saying they will support down the line
for the commission right now so all the
big players are saying yes down the line
how average person will take this
transaction and they might get more
confused or they need to do a lot of
learning in that area how my resident
will get benefit out of it rather than
putting some kind of a more complexity
in their day-to-day life so let me
answer this question so here's the key
thing we're going to have a
subcommittee and in that
subcommittee we have the the duties of
this commission so your question we can
put in as the duty of the commission to
resolve is to give you the answer to
that question he can't give it to you
this document if we pass this commission
you're free to add all these really good
questions
and make sure that the commission's
report defines and explains how this
will benefit your
constituents good thank you very much
thank
you okay got no more
cards close the public hearing we're
running behind so we'll start right in
all
right okay welcome uh thank you for
Inquisition for the record my name is
Keith Ammon Hillsboro District 42 New
Boston Mount Vernon and lineboro two
disclaimers I do own assets and I'm the
chair of the New Hampshire New Hampshire
blockchain Council which is a nonprofit
volunteer
organization uh so I'm introducing House
Bill
302 relative to enabling the state
treasury to invest in precious metals
and digital
assets so we spoke about tokenization
um this this bill the simplified version
of this bill uh there's a statute sh uh
that enables the treasur to invest in
certain things there's a list of
approved assets so this would add
basically precious
metals and digital assets above a
certain market cap to that
list um and the easiest way to do it
would be through an ETF so it basically
instead of custody gold bars in a in a
vault somewhere you would let uh a
financial institution you you'd purchase
shares of their ETF that are gold backed
right so that's similar to
tokenization um the reason that you
would want to do this we've all
experienced inflation the inflation
numbers just came out this morning 3%
inflation still currently um you so over
a a period of many years inflation eats
away at the purchasing power of the
dollar this is my opinion this is how I
how I'm thinking about this issue our
our federal government is $ 36 trillion
dollar in debt
and and
growing and you know bouncing from
crisis to
crisis every time a crisis happens they
flood the Zone with more money and that
causes inflation if you have more
dollars chasing the same amount of
goods in in dollar terms the price goes
up right and so this would allow our
state treasure to to potentially
insulate some of our reserves from
inflation
you know protecting the value of uh our
taxpayers
money um we started talking we we were
talking last year about this we talked
about gold in a different Bill last year
so gold was $2,000 an ounce a year ago
and it's currently trading at about
2650 so that's a six a 33% increase in
val in dollar
terms we were talking about Bitcoin last
year it was
$43,000 last year and to it's about
$997,000 that's
125% year-over-year now past performance
doesn't predict future results but on a
long on a long time frame because
precious metals and especially
especially Bitcoin it's a scarce
asset so gold you have to dig it out of
the ground with bulldozers and equipment
and energy and machines to get more gold
right so that a li that limits the
supply um and and Bitcoin is mined at a
fixed rate um so over a long enough time
period you can protect your purchasing
power as long as you're willing to
withstand some volatility day-to-day and
the treasurer would have to account for
that but on a longtime scale both of
those Vehicles help protect your dollar
from
eroding uh because you know it's been
the history of our federal government
they're they're not managing our money
supply correctly um we're still at 3%
inflation that's over a 10-year period
that eats away at your purchasing power
in the last few years we've lost 25 30%
of the value of the dollar you can see
that when you go to drive-thru window
and you pay $15 for a burger and fries
that's that's inflation so um that's
what this bill would do it would give
the treasurer two more tools in the
toolbox uh it's it's enabling it's not a
mandate and uh with that I'll I'll
answer any questions I'll answer a few
okay uh let's see we want start we start
with representative
Sullivan it's taking my question so I'm
just kind of curious right now are the
only tools that they have are bonds or
what Bonds in cash or CDs or what are
they using now do you
know uh so I I actually we actually met
with the treasurer yesterday and she
provided me a piece of paper that lists
the assets and I I forgot to bring it so
I can't I can't name it off the top of
my head but it's in statute it's in RSA
6 if you have your laptop you can pull
up RSA 6 and see I don't have one list
check it out I'm sorry RSA 6 you said
yeah yeah okay um follow follow for the
question
so I guess you know I hear you with
respect to and and I actually share your
concerns we we haven't done a great job
with managing our money supply so like I
but does is do you have any concerns
that things like we start going into
digital coins like that seems like
something that has a pretty low barrier
to entry so while Bitcoin itself might
have a fixed number there's like a
thousand other coins out there you know
and so you can keep and presumably it's
just like if you're buying gold just to
hold the value right well that's also
impacted because there are there are
substitutes maybe not perfect
substitutes but there are substitutes
like silver or or platinum or copper or
whatever right and so you know those
the movements of those precious metals
do impact the the the prices of other
precious metals seems to me if we enable
the treasury to buy um various tokens as
they come out or digital currencies it
seems like that the potential for them
to be diluted is pretty high
particularly when right now we don't
have a regulatory environment nationally
or or at the local level to deal with
that that that's the part of this bill
that concerns me all right I can I can
answer that part if you want okay sure
um so in in the bill there is a limit on
U I'm just trying to find it here with
my glasses here
um it there's a there's a limit on
market capitalization of digital assets
and it sets it at 500 billion dollars
which is half a trillion so anything
below
500 half of a trillion average market
cap the previous year would be off
limits and so that's see that's a check
that's the check yeah uh on on you know
I doubt the treasur would want to invest
in meme coins you know there's all kinds
of meme coins and that's crazy
speculation so those those would all be
uh prevent prevented prohibited from
being invested in gotcha yeah
okay okay representative ml uh thank you
very much Mr chairman um I guess I don't
know this but um to me these are type of
assets that belong in a long-term
investment how much long-term money does
the State Treasury have do they do they
hold part of our pen funds so we we I I
actually learned about that yesterday
meeting with the treasurer um so they
have an operating budget that's all
shortterm yep we have the rainy day fund
um that fluctuates in value there might
be some long-term possibility with a
very small amount what we're talking
about is one% half of a percent 2% Max
right it's very small amount does it
well does a state do any investing in in
a pension so that's where I was going
that that's what we were told yesterday
that there are you know pensions have to
have 20year Horizons right so and that
that would probably be an area that they
so
question representative Herbert uh would
you
believe uh
that um the the
dollar is the strongest currency on the
planet
yeah would you believe that when people
say question for the question would you
believe that uh when you say um the
dollar is um being
devalued would you believe there is
never have we have never the treasury
has never lost or
defaulted uh on on the treasury
Securities and we bought our first
Treasury secur Security in
1791 what was the security it was a
treasury so so the my point I'm trying
to make is that when you start talking
about debt and it's out of control and
that sort of thing you are not really
understanding a currency I think I am I
think I do understand it and I the
Dollar's value does the Dollar by by the
way the dollar so we we're really not
discussing the value of the dollar that
is not what this bills about okay so
let's just kind of stick to the focus is
do we want to give the state treasurer
the power to invest in a different kind
of product than what she has have
historically been able to do it's
another tool in the toolbox um it's just
just another V big Financial firms like
Black Rock I I just rattling off off the
top of my head they they suggest a 2%
allocation in Bitcoin for every
portfolio because it's it's a new asset
class so it helps to balance out the
risk of your entire Port portfolio it's
a you know you're diversifying your
portfolio right EXA black rocket is a
huge Bitcoin owner yeah and so is
Fidelity there you go yeah so all right
represent yes
represent uh so thank you for taking a
question you stated in your uh
presentation the bright side of Bitcoin
going from 40,000 to ,000 in one year
but I'm sure you're aware that just a
year ago in 2022 it also fell down from
60,000 to less than 177,000 yeah losing
almost 34 of the value how have you so
would you believe that uh adding that
kind of uh Security in the to hedge the
risk is it really hedging the risk or is
really creating more risk for the funds
well you're always retirement funds
there's always risk in an investment um
if if you look back at 10 years and I
will not uh I I totally disagree I
totally agree with you that there is
volatility in in digital assets 100%
especially because you you but wait so
is the stock market yeah no but Johnson
and Johnson was like the one of the
hottest stocks around until someone
decided their baby powder was bad excuse
me Mr my follow question that because
the I because the main subject was
hedging the risk wanted to add to has
the risk but here the risk is more risky
than the normal assets or asset classes
is much more riskier why do you want to
add a much riskier asset to hedge the
risk itself that was that was the main
concern fair enough good question yeah
good question why would you want to add
that to your portfolio so so it's a it's
an uh non an uncorrelated asset so as
the stock market goes down there's
potential for Bitcoin to go up right and
it it's it's not guaranteed
in any by any means but that's why you'd
want to have different asset classes in
a portfolio this is just enabling this
is this is not a prescriptive bill this
is just here's a tool you can use it if
you want to uh to the state treasurer
that that's all this bill does further
question you may inquire yeah a further
question uh well I did not still what do
you believe that I I still didn't
getting an answer that I understand that
you you want to have different
instruments for trading or for
investment because your objective is to
safeguard the investment and also to
reduce to hedge the to hedge the risk
itself reduce the risk itself so the
concern that I have I mean would you
believe that adding such much riskier
asset which can lose just 34 value
within a year and nobody understand
why and and and can gain 34 times value
in another year adding that kind of
asset to a to a fund to really reduce
the risk itself the objective I mean
investment is one thing but your
objective of reducing the risk hedging
and adding the riskier product doesn't
really VI with me fair enough that's a
personal opinion that's you know that's
would you believe would you believe yeah
would you believe okay representative
um my question um it's a little complex
but uh it has to do with what bit coin
is backed by okay um when you have a
dollar inflation not withstanding you
have something that's backed by the full
faith and credit of the United States
let me finish my question um when you
invest in gold you have something which
is backed by a gold bar when you invest
in the stock market you have something
which is backed by an actual company now
none of this is is risk-free I'm not
claiming that it is um the dollar may be
subject to inflation stock may go up or
down so may the price of gold but my
question is what is bit Bitcoin or any
other cryptocurrency what are they
backed
by
um so it's backed by Bitcoin with its
proof of work consensus algorithm that's
footnote talk about that later it's
backed by energy and it's backed by
mathematics that's what backs Bitcoin
energy and mathematics followup question
well here's the point at the end of the
day if the state treasurer has got to
stand up and say that the investment is
legitimate and you know who the
regulator in that case is the bonding
companies they're not going to you know
we want to maintain our AAA bonding or
double A plus whatever we are in New
Hampshire he is not going to put
something in her portfolio in our
portfolio that that bonding company's
going to say is that's some that's too
risky and so therefore there are plenty
of Governors to ensure that the state
treasurer won't do uh take buy a sketchy
Bitcoin asset that that they're you know
all they're saying is if that if time
change right we're talking about going
to the Future now if there's a point in
time that there will be a commodity
maybe with our after this commission and
years after this commission they'll
create one that's but is is a a very
viable entity then why would we want to
Bar the me from putting that in our
state portfolio if she knows full or she
or he or wherever it will be then uh
knows full well that this would be a
benefit to the state um may I ask a
follow-up question yes thank you um so
algorithm uh yeah in in a way you could
put it that way sure yeah fair
enough okay and this is just a
conversation right every piece of
legislation is just a conversation and
we can you know set safeguards on this
or not do it at all right this is just
presenting an idea and uh right now it's
it limits it to 10% that's probably too
high you know 10% of assets we we can
make that lower so right um always open
to helpful you know
amendments one little question yes one
little question I have a little question
I've spent some time talking to the
treasurer in the past on other bills and
she seemed kind of conservative so when
you talk to her about this did she start
throwing darts at you or anything I
thought she would laugh us out of her
office and and she was very uh
hospitable and inviting and I I won't
you know I I don't want to represent
what our conversation was but I came
with a needle no I came with that she
was uh curious about it so that's that
her okay thank you very much all right
thank you very much okay uh we'll call
McCarthy good morning Mr chair yeah you
have to hit the little button there
because red is red is green here good
morning Mr chair and representatives of
the Commerce and consumer affairs
committee thank you for the opportunity
to provide testimony in favor of house
Bill 302 which would allow the state of
New Hampshire to invest and hold
precious metals and digital assets such
as Bitcoin and stable coins my name is
Thomas Mccarthy and I live in Northern
Virginia just outside of Washington DC I
work for Satoshi action fund we are a
nonprofit organization dedicated to
promoting education and advocacy for
Bitcoin and digital assets at the state
level we have supported Bitcoin and
digital asset legislation that has
passed in multiple States and I'm
grateful for the opportunity to speak to
speak with all of you today critical
responsibility of the state and of uh
New Hampshire is to safeguard the value
of public funds that provide essential
services to New Hampshire residents We
Believe hb32 will provide New Hampshire
with more tools to achieve these goals
since Bitcoin was first regulated by the
Commodities future trading Commission in
2018 its adoption and utility as a
financial asset has expanded
significantly leading to a dramatic
increase in its price over this same
period the purchasing power of dollars
held by New Hampshire has been steadily
eroded due to inflation by approximately
25% even Bond strategies have not been
immune since investing in treasury bonds
would have still seen a decrease in
value by approximately
10% however just a small allocation in
into Bitcoin could have offset these
losses and you could have see all this
information in the chart
provided this troubling Trend
underscores the important need for new
Financial strategies in the treasures
toolbox and to protect the purchas
purchasing power of funds and trusted to
New Hampshire by its residents last year
Utah passed HB 348 which allows the
state treasur in Utah to invest in
Precious Metals building on this
progress Satoshi action fund is working
with those Bill sponsors to increase the
scope of the legislation to include high
quality digital assets such as Bitcoin
we are waiting and expect this
legislative update to be introduced
shortly other states are following suit
North Dakota heard this legislation
yesterday and we
Oklahoma Kansas Iowa Montana Utah
Wyoming and others to introduce similar
legislation one concern we have heard is
how the state of New Hampshire would
Safeguard its digital asset Holdings and
custody and and provide secure custody
solutions to ensure that digital assets
acquired are protected so we are
proposing that these assets are
protected by robust technological and
governance Frameworks the legislation
stipulates that stringent requirements
are enhanced and these options can
include either implementing
state-ofthe-art secure custody
technology or partnering with federal
and state banks that hold highly
regulated exchange traded products
Additionally the bill requires the
Investments be limited to digital assets
with the market capitalization of over
500 billion which ensures that only the
most established and stable digital
assets are considered currently only
Bitcoin meets this
requirement under the legislation stable
coins must be backed by US dollars or
short-term government bonds and are
subject to us regulatory oversight
ensuring the stability and
reliability the economic challenges over
the past few years have underscored the
importance of proactive and adaptive
policym states that fail to modernize
their investment strategies risk falling
behind and losing their purchasing power
to inflation hb32 provides New Hampshire
with tools in needs to stay ahead
protect the services provided by the
state and serve as a model for other
states seeking to navigate the
challenging Financial landscape thank
you for your time and I look forward to
questions okay we are going to have a
subcomittee on this bill
okay you really need to ask this
question representa
gives okay well you know I just want you
to know we're going to be cutting into
lunch pretty soon here because we're way
behind go ahead make it quick um you
said that um currencies such as Bitcoin
could be subject to Heavy R regulation
are they currently subject to regulation
state or federal so the answer your
question thank you for your question
representative yes though they are
regulated at the state level this is a
common misconception when people say
digital assets are not regulated they're
regulated at the state level here in DC
where where I where I currently reside
um they're working on federal
legislation also a point of
clarification Bitcoin is money it's not
currency currency is different from
money currency can be used as money and
then also to your question in the
previous with representative emmen I
wanted to answer and say that Bitcoin is
backed by math code and open source
software
okay yes
represent uh thank you for any question
I'll be quick I just want to uh um would
you believe that the financial crisis of
2008 had happened because of investing
in riskier and people didn't understand
the instrument like cdos which a lot of
complex algorithms which Normal
public and even a lot of banks and lot
of financial wiers didn't understand
much now you are proposing uh in
introducing this in the treasury would
you believe that that's going to make
the treasury uh more riskier rather than
safeguarding
it so um for my understanding and again
I don't come from a finance background
but one of the issues that led to the
2008 U banking crisis is that the banks
didn't know who hell who was their party
and so one of the key aspects of
blockchain technology is you can know
who owns what when now I do not believe
adding Bitcoin into this uh to the
state's balance sheet will will increase
risk simply because at the end of the
day you know the market is the ultimate
referee and over the last 10 years over
the last decade Bitcoin has been the
best performing asset and what I mean by
that is that it's like you know sure
maybe an exotic car or a fine art
painting uh would have increased its
value more so than Bitcoin but I'm we're
here talking about a widely available
asset that's available to be purchased
by you know the common person as well as
States and there's been no other asset
that someone can point me to that has
outperformed Bitcoin over the last
decade thank
you okay yes okay okay all right thank
you very much for letting me ask the
question thank you for your expertise so
you mentioned that there is legislation
uh pending in many different states and
I'm assuming that you were aware of what
what's what they're
proposing and uh in reading this bill do
you have any recommendations for maybe
updates or something that we would want
to think about for an amendment or did
you think this bill is similar to what
other states are
passing thank you representa for your
question so truthfully what I really
what I really like about this bill and
and as as representative Ammon has said
before all it is is really enabling and
so and even in our conversation with
multiple State treasurers you know what
we really want to do is lay the
groundwork so that we don't expect a
decision to be made to purchase Bitcoin
immediately it's going to take time and
it seems like a lot of people here are
interested in learning I'm always happy
to explain and and answer questions so
essentially for me I think this is a
really good stepping stone so that you
know should one two years down in the
future once every starts everyone starts
to become comfortable and can and are
ready to make the purchase and allocate
one or 2% into Bitcoin the leg work and
the ground work has already been done
and that you no longer have to you know
waste more time to allocate more into
Bitcoin because the last thing I'll say
is um you know I think a lot of people
didn't expect Bitcoin to reach 100,000
and I fully expect this asset class to
be worth in the millions in the future
when I can't tell you but you know I
think it'd be prudent to ensure that you
know this residents of New Hampshire
have access to the best performing asset
class over the last
decade great thank you very much thank
Mii
Mii yeah y Yi yuch thank you Yi Uchi
that's a you not an N okay y sorry
um you know I I wasn't sure if I should
pass this out but I just did a like a
little spreadsheet and I have about
eight eight copies would you like why
don't you save that for the subcommittee
next week okay great
um uh good morning everyone my name is
Michael yuchi I again I live in Bedford
New Hampshire with my family and um uh I
have two kids and a wife uh by the way
um my background again is a entrepreneur
and investor and I appreciate living in
one of the freest States uh in the
country I support
hb32 because it's important that uh NH
New Hampshire Safeguard itself from debt
and inflation that's kind of how I see
it I'm not trying to be political or
anything and that and I know
representative Amon uh
uh is one of the sponsors of this bill I
I don't know him very well I only met
him once before just as a uh uh only
talked about this once before and I and
I'll tell you how um uh you know New
Hampshire has about 10 billion in debt
if I get that correctly I'm not trying
to um uh sound critical or anything it
has about 10 billion in debt as far as I
know and there's approximately 1.4
million people here uh uh since 2023 I
could have that wrong wrong but um let's
say about one that's about $7,000 of
debt per person family of four like me
is about
$28,000 so I was just thinking how can a
person like me a family person I just
take care of my family that's all I do
I'm not political I just want to take
care of my family how can uh uh you know
how can we deal with this and and I just
came to a thought of creating a Bitcoin
strategic reserve for the
state so I contact Ed my local state
senator I just uh sent her an email a
friend of mine and she introduced me to
Representative Keith Ammon so um he told
me about Bill 302 and that's how I came
come to know it and I and I thought it
was a fantastic idea especially because
it's much more
diverse it's a diverse fund it would be
a diverse fund uh of assets than simply
holding Bitcoin I mean you can do gold
and silver and as an investor I I'm
doing all of that uh on a personal
basis so some experts
say that Bitcoin has grown
60% since its Inception I know it goes
up and down but volatile but good
investments just like the internet
stocks were very volatile Google was
very volatile in the beginning so some
others say when it when it stabilizes
Bitcoin can grow 30% a year and I just
want to present a spreadsheet you um you
can all look at it later uh I just want
to see what what a 20-year chart might
look like it's just speculation but I
just want to see what it might look like
in 20 years uh and so I would say that
I'm not a financial expert this is not
Financial advice and I can't guarantee
any of these numbers but if the general
fund uh uh which is I heard something
like 250 million if it invested uh uh
you know uh invested a partial
amount in there uh and you know we're
looking at right now and I didn't
discuss any of this uh these numbers
these kind of inflation rates with uh
representative Ammon it just happens to
be by
coincidence if we if we're running it
around 5 to 10% which you know owning
real estate here in the in the state
I've seen prices almost double uh in the
last five seven years uh so real rate of
inflation at 5 to 10% there the fund is
theoretically $250 million general fund
for the state you're losing 1225 billion
a year in real purchasing power
so uh in short uh uh
hb32 makes a lot of sense and I ask you
to support it uh especially because it
has a chance to make the state very
wealthy on the positive side thank you
for your time if you have any questions
I think we're all questioned out thank
you
thank okay have one more card left uh
H thank you chair um sorry my
handwriting isn't very good but it's uh
Nicholas
slany oh sweet okay thanks for the
opportunity to speak good morning to the
chair and to the committee uh my name is
Nicholas slany and I'm from Hopkinson
I'm an engineer by trade
I've been a bitcoiner since 2013 and
have had the opportunity in the last
couple years to build a business on
bitcoin at block I was also selected to
serve as an expert on the recent
Commission on digital assets for the
governor with representative
Ammon Bitcoin was created to provide a
truly neutral money for the world that
anyone can use being truly neutral means
that no one including our own government
can control Bitcoin and that is nearly
impossible to change but I don't think
Bitcoin is against our state's interests
the best governments in the world adopt
Bitcoin and I want my home state of New
Hampshire to be an early adopter in that
group why consider
this technology is a lever a tool with
every new invention Humanity gets bigger
levers take the written word for example
what used to be done with large machines
like printing presses can now be done
with by tweets with finger Taps
similarly similarly in the field of
wiretapping we used to take specialized
equipment switchboard access and most
not notably warrant now is Trivial in
widespread to the point where the FBI
advises a use spend and encryption for
Communications in the case of money we
are at a fork in the road the technology
is here and the quadrillion dollar
question is who gets to use the lever
the impact of our path is outsized
because with the technology we have now
removing the ability for someone to buy
groceries could like a tweet just
require a finger
tap if our adversaries are Russia and
China our government should lean as far
as possible towards things that give us
advantage over them freedom of speech
freedom of movement freedom of money all
lead to technology vov Tech
technological innovation and ultimately
bigger levers open systems like Bitcoin
are part of our advantage over our
adversaries I would like to see my
government adopt this technology before
our enemies do so for the committee here
are the three reasons to go forward with
House Bill
302 Bitcoin isly aligned with the state
of New Hampshire's values holding
Bitcoin is actively choosing the path of
Freedom over total
control being an early adopter relative
to our peers nationally and
internationally is a great Advantage for
the system citizens of New Hampshire in
aligning our state with the vision of an
open Future puts our state in a position
to be a leader going into the future I
don't think the alternative is something
anyone in the state wants thank you for
questions I guess we're all set thank
you very much thank you
uh having no more cards I will close the
public
hearing this is 359 so 302 okay uh rep
representative
Penza thank you Mr chair my name is
representative Kelly penai I represent
Strafford District 19
um I've been posting about this for the
last couple days I really believe that
people need to learn the truth in the
prepare um Gold and Silver Platinum sure
we could do that I I think that thinking
about how it would be stored in all of
those types of things creates um some
issues but Bitcoin hard no it's also
unconstitutional Article 1 Section 10
Clause one is clear no State shall enter
into any treaty Alliance or
Confederation Grant letters of Mark or
reprisal coin money admit bills of
credit make anything but gold and silver
coin ATT tender and payment of debts we
should all know that because we took a
oath to both the New Hampshire and the
US
Constitution I believe it's an
absolutely ludicrous idea I've got no
issue with the idea of government
holding Bitcoin assets they've seized to
be sold off either small portions at a
time or utilized in situations where
Bitcoin assets could be used in some
kind of law enforcement sting operation
but the idea that we'd put tax revenue
into acquiring more of a very volatile
asset that has no obviously obvious
day-to-day use feels more like economic
gamesmanship versus a logical strategic
move oil we can understand reserves as
well as food ammunition Etc if Bitcoin
actually had succeeded in its initial
aim of becoming a digital fiat currency
there would be some logic to it but with
the Absurd price points per coin these
days it's just become another tool for
investment and speculation the elite
Powers try to destroy everything that's
money related that is truly private
meaning Not underneath government World
Bank cbdc tethers AKA any peer-to-peer
electronic cash systems with their own
economies this is done through
delistings censoring Banning of accounts
and price suppression they know people
can have money freedom only by private
means backed by legit money not
paper so this is a big huge um news it's
happening of course on a national level
um but I think everybody especially if
you have a subcommittee you should all
probably buy the book and I'll buy it
for you it's called hijacking Bitcoin so
Al savador Bitcoin experiment um has
failed um the shivo wallet is going to
be shut down El Salvador now has to
collect taxes in the US dollar Bitcoin
is effectively no longer legal tender
and the IMF which is the international
country um tether and Bitcoin strategic
Reserve could possibly become the most
significant financial fraud in US
history Bitcoin and tether need to be
exposed before the US taxpayer gets the
rug out from underneath them and I also
believe that all politicians that are
proposing State reserves throughout this
country um should have all of their P
personal conflicts examined so I
strongly oppose this bill unless it was
amended to just include Gold and Silver
Platinum um and that's where I
stand fair enough thanks thank you very
much can I ask a question oh would you
question re in a post could you give me
a copy of that please yes I will email
it to you couldn't write very fast okay
okay thank you very much having no more
cards I will now close the public
302 and we'll get into our last but
least okay
uh it's sponsor represent I know not
sure I have a card from you but I know
you're
here
plesent is there a
representative is the sponsor in the
room
is representative corkran in the
room guess I thought it was it not it's
not her can't do
anything oh my
God okay I don't see belter don't see
[Music]
Barry you're doing you right you want to
introduce um uh no that's all right you
know what you want to introduce
it no pusk wants to do
it okay right
no is there anybody anybody in the room
in support of this
359 can I make a
comment Mr chair killing me yes um this
looks Vaguely Familiar to a bill that
came before us uh maybe one or two
sessions ago which we soundly defeated
thank
um okay so I just need someone to you
want you just go in and open the bill
because I know that's what people want
all right so we will make it to lunch
after
all disclaimer as Vice chair this is one
duties uh uh representative pusk
introducing House Bill
3594 representative corkin from
Hillsboro 28 prohibiting denial of
banking and insurance services based on
any factor that is not quantitative
impartial and risk-based as measured by
standard thank you very
much okay uh we'll start all right so
emphasize to everyone in the room here
okay to everybody's in opposition we got
it clear that we don't have anybody here
who wants to speak towards this bill so
I would say uh please keep your
testimony to two minutes Ryan not five
to seven minutes where okay let's just
just see if we can get through this
because I think we pretty the committee
most of the committee OB the new members
this is a new issue but for the members
of the committee we all we've been down
this path before okay so Alexander
Sakowski from the New Hampshire
Department
of Justice which I apologize you looked
like representative Corran to me all the
way back
here
no person so I would just say if you had
your B you had a badge on here I would
have known you haven't got a badge yet
okay good so tell them that you were you
were reprimanded but no it's just tell
that that if you were if you had a badge
then you might would not be confused
with a member of the house so good
afternoon
morning Alexandra snaski Assistant
Attorney General with the New Hampshire
doj and the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau I am here primarily
regarding um the two Provisions that
make a violation of this act an unfair
or deceptive actor practice under the
consumer protection act RSA
358a um there is an exemption under RSA
35831 um that exempts from our statute
um trade or Commerce right under the
jurisdiction of banking or insurance so
we would be unable to enforce
this
so I have to admit as the architect of
that statute is I was wondering how why
she was in here and now I know so here
we are great thank you very much
okay uh next up the bankers New
Hampshire Bankers
association yes I see you the two of you
oh oh the banker commission is here I
didn't I didn't see your card
sorry what's
that
uh uh uh okay no that's fine come on up
yeah no we we
we would only honor the commissioner
lobbyist good morning good morning uh
for the record my name is Amelia Galder
uh Bank commissioner for the State of
New Hampshire with me is general counsel
Seth
saraki um thank you for the opportunity
to provide testimony on this bill we're
going to keep it real short because um
this is very similar to a bill that came
before you um I think last session or
maybe the session before it um my
testimony is largely the same the only
addition that I would point out from the
start is that we did not get a fiscal
note request for this bill um and I do
believe that if we were to have to
enforce this bill or the text of this
bill um we would need probably an
attorney as well as a financial examiner
I would in anticipate an increased
volume of complaints that we would have
to process um and it would probably take
that amount of staff to do that because
this is something totally new um we
would have a lot of issues to work out
with it um so that would be a difference
from I believe the last time we got a
fiscal note request um so that's one
thing and then we have a a myriad of
enforceability issues that I'm happy to
go through at a subcommittee on this if
necessary um but I don't want to belabor
it so if you would like to hear those I
can go through them but happy to well I
guess
um how often you've had complaints never
not You' never heard on this subject
matter no no one's ever called up and
said you know I get I get no but
sometimes when laws like this if it were
to pass I would anticipate some
confusion um and generally confusion
generates calls and inquiries and
complaints um from consumers so we've
had nothing to date um additionally this
bill seems to Encompass National Banks
which we don't have jurisdiction over
anyways um anyways um I think it would
probably we create conflicts with um
several federal laws that banks have to
comply with um that we do examine for
such as Bank secrecy act um countering
the finance of terrorism anti-money
laundering laws
um I think that's right not withstanding
the fact that there's an actual
exemption under the consumer protection
statute so that that you're this because
it I I didn't did did it refer to your
statute it's in our statute so they're
putting it into our I don't that's 358a
no 3 yeah 3 no 383a is our statute okay
so so the AG and we do so we can
investigate unfair and deceptive acts
right well I know you have that yes so I
think I don't know that's the whole
reason why we Exempted you from three
correct is because you already had your
own separate correct okay all
right any questions from the committee
members see oh representative post can I
just get a card from you of course thank
you thank you very much thank you
okay all right
Rob I promise it will not be 5 to seven
minutes and I will not be reading I will
hold you to my testimony good um
chairman hunt Vice chairman pusk
honorable members of the House Commerce
consumer affairs committee for the
record my name is Ryan hail vice
president of uh government relations for
New Hampshire Bankers Association um
alongside with me I have Rob deedle our
general counsel from the Gallagher Cal
control Law Firm here in conquer
um uh as you've heard this is this is
very similar to past two proposals that
this committee has heard um just like
those past two proposals we were in
strong opposition uh to those um and
I'll just highlight the reasons why um
I've passed around my testimony which
will elaborate on these reasons but um
I'll just start with a VI it's a
violation of the free market principles
um it's unnecessary and duplicative um
it creates a scenario where Banks would
be guilty until proven innocent and a
lot there are scenarios where it would
be very difficult for them to prove
their innocence um it would erode uh
risk-based decision making increases
Regulatory and legal uncertainty and um
there's several unattended consequences
for consumers including but not limited
to potential of um limiting banking
opportunities uh due to the um impact
that this potentially could have on
smaller banks that would just decide to
leave the market um so with that I will
conclude my brief testimony and uh
opening up for any questions committee
members may have or if there's anything
Rob would like to add I would just say
that I'll I'll second what commissioner
garyi said in terms of the concerns of
reconciling this with national and uh
law thank you very much you're very
welcome beautiful okay we got through
banking now we'll do insurance George
russos representing domestic insurance
minutes well since you wrote half of
them I don't think you really need to
read
them thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee happy to be here
here still this morning and I will be
very brief I'm here on behalf of two
clients one is the New Hampshire
Association of domestic insurance
companies uh and the second is the
American property and casual insurance
Association together they represent
companies that write most of the
property Casualty Insurance business in
the state of New Hampshire I did bring
these books along
to take a EXC journey through these are
the insurance statutes that there there
are 36 of these volumes and two of them
are devoted to insurance and insurance
regulation um the point being that the
behaviors that are described in this
bill uh most of them that would not be
allowed and are not engaged in by uh
insurance companies they're prohibited
under existing statutes and some of them
are behaviors that the way they are
written uh would prohibit uh
underwriting activity that is important
uh to insurance companies and and that
benefits the public because of the way
it's drafted so I'm happy to leave it at
that Mr chairman and answer any
questions thank you all right you really
impress everybody this
time all all right he is in opposition
to the bill correct okay so uh then we
Farm good morning Mr chairman and
committee members my name is Kiren
Schultz I'm here with my colleague Jim
hadam uh and we're here on behalf of
State Farm insurance companies uh they
are one of the leading writers of auto
and home insurance in the United States
and here in New Hampshire um we would
like to respectfully note our opposition
to HB 359 as drafted and very briefly uh
New Hampshire has a healthy market for
homeowners and auto insurance as it is
um what works best for a healthy Market
is that insurance is readily available
and
affordable and underwriting freedom is
key to the availability and
affordability of insurance this Bill
appears uh intended to restrict those
freedoms and that would uh most likely
pass along the risks relating to
protected classes under this bill uh to
other
consumers and insurance companies we
think do best in contributing to the
healthy Market environment when they're
able to price risk
appropriately uh in their premiums and
when we start Crossing off of the list
some things that they're allowed to
consider or not we need to be be really
careful about that and so at a high
level those are our reasons for opposing
the bill I'm happy to take any questions
thank
you thank you very much thank
you uh Michael moffen representing All
State
Insurance good morning Mr chairman and
members of the community Min is Michael
mlon I represent all state New Hampshire
excuse me All State Insurance Company
New Hampshire Maine in Vermont
uh just like to briefly uh reiterate
some of the remarks the people have made
and as George showed with this analog
display of the of the uh highly
regulated industry the industry has been
regulated uh and has the opportunity uh
to self-regulate itself through the
Department of Insurance the
representative hunt in his past uh
efforts created the uh ability for the
insurance department to actually find uh
insurers for misconduct and uh as you
saw earlier the um the industry because
we're already highly regul there's
nothing in this bill that isn't covered
today by the insurance by the insurance
department so as you look at the bill it
provides nothing that's not already in
place and we oppose the bill and we
thank you for your time and effort and
hope you all have a great
session thank you very much mik okay and
last but not least is Michelle VC from
nbsr I'm not sure I know what nbsr is
well good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to speak it is New Hampshire
businesses for social responsibility
we're over 250 businesses throughout New
Hampshire that are focused on
sustainable business practices we are
here to um share our opposition to the
bill because we feel that it limits
businesses and their ability to be able
to make sound financial decisions and so
we hope that you will um also feel the
same way and um beyond that I don't
think I need to elaborate any further
so are you like representing B Corps or
uh yes many of our many of our members
oh you uh somehow pink cards disappeared
so come on up and fill out another one
is is it
no I can we got we got everybody here
this it's who knows it's all good uh
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you uh my name is
Brendan flare I'm here with the DuPont
group on behalf of series um series is a
uh nonprofit and I have the brief one
sentence here a nonprofit sustainability
organization uh that works with uh
companies and investors um to advance
market-based solutions to sustainability
challenges and at the risk of sounding
like a broken record uh they also stand
opposed to House Bill 359 for the
reasons that our colleagues have uh also
stated the bottom line is that uh this
prohibits uh free market operation of uh
Banks and undermines fiduciary duties so
um I'll leave it there I think I got it
in the nick of time any questions I'm
happy to
take perfect okay thank you very much
than you having no more cards on spill
359 we'll close the public hearing and
uh the chair will state that uh next
Wednesday
morning we will do the liquor bills and
when these three bills we just heard we
1:15 these are business these are
business banking bills
yeah no the subcommittee we're
subcommittee sub commmittee
subcommittees sorry I we're not I'm not
ready to exact yet yeah are we okay we
still have we still have two two more
yeah we have two other bills in the this
afternoon
okay
e
your bill oh okay all
spe
top yeah I had an idea you have with you
good afternoon welcome to the afternoon
session of the Commerce Committee our
first bill will be House Bill 3
316 uh and representative hunt will be
introducing it thank you good afternoon
members of the
committee um for those of you who uh who
have been on this committee you know
this is sort of a deja vu all over again
and for you new new
members uh buckle your seat Bel because
you're about to deal with one of the
most complicated issues this committee
years
so I will I thought I was close enough
but is that better okay um so what we
have here today is uh as promised by uh
we left it last year which is that the
insurance department was going to delve
deep into the cost of ambulance
service the problem of ambulance service
is that it's uh and and I'll be frank
it's it is run by the you know many fire
departments it is very similar to your
fire department in your town in the
sense that uh you're paying for them to
be
there
and you could go a week with no
calls and who pays for
that the issue has uh
uh comes down to the balance billing
issue and the balance billing issue um
we we in this committee have solved when
it came to everybody else all other
types of providers when there was
balance building involved we we've been
able to solve that issue but this is the
one that hangs out
there uh even the federal government
they would they dealt with it when it
came to helicopters and ambulance
service but they left this one hanging
out there with no
resolution so we had the interns
Department really investigate in terms
of you know doing an economic analysis
and with the sole purpose of how do we
how do we get to a place where we can
find to
convince Medicare and Medicaid or
Medicare in particular who was really
the highest user of ambulance service
how do we convince them to increase
their reimbursement rates um is that
we're taking the step that we're going
to address it uh by having a good handle
on what exactly it is costing for these
Services um just to briefly you know
describe the difficulty of the problems
is this is absolutely an urban versus
rural issue U and Ro is you you you have
much smaller population and longer
distances to go so it is just uh kind of
exponential increases the
problems so this legislation um will as
you will hear uh does not please those
uh in the fire departments now who do
balance
billing because we're going to uh in
this bill we we're going to bar balance
billing because we're saying we're now
rates in defense of what we would do I
would say here is that I I truly believe
Ambulance Service is like your fire
department or your police
department and that is you're it's a
cost of the town it's a cost of the
community and and I I absolutely
understand that um it's more expensive
almost the ambulances are are you know
we my County cheser County uh believe it
or not is we actually we started our own
ambulance service and and so uh as a
member of the executive committee I'm in
intimately involved in what is the
financial burden that this these uh
ambulance services provide to the county
and the towns are that are using it and
we see firsthand you know what exactly
the cost is and it's and it's a it's a
big Bill to the
towns that's just the reality and to say
is okay let's let's back Bill and and
balance bill to the people who are using
it um when you know like I say we don't
do that for the fire if you're if you
got if you had a fire in your house we
don't say oh but you're you're not only
unlucky to have that fire but we're
going to send you a bill because it
costs us money to send those trucks
there um I believe ambulance services is
similar to police and fire and yes
there's going to be a cost to the town
cost to the
community uh but at the end of the day
we'll do what we as a legislature to do
our part by ensuring that the insurance
companies um are providing a reasonable
and fair
compensation and that's what this bill
questions representative
Sullivan excuse me so I know you said we
here soon that
the people behind you are going to be
preferring balanced billing why is the
current why is this what do you think is
being improved in this thing versus the
current system that we have now which
apparently people are going to fight you
on done basically um what we're doing is
is saying that that for people who have
health insurance you know have have the
insurance that um they shouldn't be
balance build and that if it you know
the fact that the balance billing that
occur is um we shouldn't be penalizing
them because they call the ambulance
service and that it is the end of the
day that service being there is a
service provided by their communities by
their
towns and uh and whatever however the
town can work its best price whether it
has its own ambulance service you know
through the fire department or whether
in our case whether they use the Chester
County one in my town we actually have a
nonprofit that's uh it's just Jaffrey
and rench and they've had their
struggles and and Lord knows they uh
this year they're uh they they just
bought a new half a million dollar truck
and and and ringe is going to see a
tripling of what it has to pay uh to the
to that Ambulance Company um to help
offset the cost of that new vehicle for
question for question manire so
um I'm just thinking if I remember
correctly from the last time we had
these
discussions it wasn't always necessarily
people in the community who
were the the PR but oftentimes it was
somebody from wherever Boston on
vacation I obviously represent Bethlehem
Franconia there's Hiers SK
Resort somebody gets hurt they get
hauled away on the ambulance
um and then they are out of town like
it's
not so that just Falls purely on the
Bethlehem
taxpayers uh and so balance billing
would go after them versus even the New
Hampshire State Rep like I understand
there are plenty of places in this this
state where there are no tourism but
where I live is it's heavy tourist our
whole economy is based on tourism so how
does it impact that because that to me
seems like a slightly different thing
that if we got rid of balance billing
but simply had the people who have state
state insurance um it might screw over
places like Bethlehem where we have a
lot of people getting hurt hiking the
franconian not or whatever um and you
like like like how do you foresee that
impacting communities like mine um I
mean it's it's uh it it's a product of
that community what you're what go the
nature of your community I mean I always
think about you know the old saying
don't tax me don't tax him tax the guy
behind the tree and the guy behind the
tree was the one that came from
Massachusetts and so I understand that
you know for some people that they would
say we don't have a problem here uh we
we the problem is is Medicare you the
problem is Medicare doesn't their
reimbursement rates too low um and but
obviously we can't we have no control
over that
we can hope to we have a process set up
in this build that that we hopefully can
convince Medicare to raise their
reimbursement rates but there's no
guarantee of that um but at the end of
the day I yes every Community has their
own unique situations I mean one of the
problems we have is people the the
ambulance arrives and the person says oh
I don't want to I don't want to pay the
bill and says I ref didn't refuse to get
into the
ambulance and you know
nobody gets paid at that point
so it's a complicated problem but we're
trying to come up with a reasonable
legislative solution uh for the best
that we can do as the insurance
committee here in the house and that is
to is to at least make sure that our
insurance companies um have a a re a
reasonable payment paying back that that
that is reasonably rationalized and it's
by actual aial studies of what it really
you know what the costs are and um um it
you know obviously it's not a perfect
world because the reality is that that
insurance is you know is it's only you
know at best a third of what of the
ambulance calls but but everybody you
know you know there so often over the
years I mean we have we'll have another
bill that you'll will I hadn't got it
yet so I would have scheduled it for
today but um which goes back to what we
had last last year um where senat
Apprentice wanted to charge 300% of of
Medicaid you know and you just you know
to do a pick a number like that out of
the air just doesn't make sense we we
got to be rationalized we got to have a
a rational number and that's that's what
you representative
Spar so I watched all the videos of that
they present did when they were going
through the uh generating the the
numbers uhhuh and I know that they
interviewed as many of the ambulance
services as they could and who would
respond to it they did a really good job
of that and what the bill came out the
one that we're looking at the 316
reflects what the commission came up
with so that part is good but my
question
is like you mentioned the big hole here
is Medicare people medic care folks do
we have any leverage to push them to up
their
rates do we have any way because when we
left it last year this is a federal they
said we can do something
but all we can do is we hope that that
by doing this we can then um convince
Medicare we can uh that that they the
rat should be reflective of what we're
doing by our insurance so who talks to
them we we all the insurance ins
department will you they will okay
originally we were going to try to do it
as a waiver but I'm not sure that was
but thank you CH chairman
hunt no you're the
hun okay
Stringham uh yes thank you uh Mr chair
uh my name is Jerry Stringham I'm the
State Rep uh from Lincoln and Woodstock
area uh this my third term here um uh we
have a great ambulance service up there
it's a nonprofit it's not a fire
department uh uh thing I'll be heading
up there tonight to listen to their
presentations to a couple of towns
asking for a lot of money just to stay
in business um you know we know for the
last several terms we've been dealing uh
with the collapse of the ambulance
industry I'm very appreciative of the
people here uh and I'm appreciative of
the work uh that led to uh to the bill
being presented uh here
um uh to move the needle towards having
a viable long-term ambulance industry uh
I um my background um probably more
important than I'm a State Rep is I
formed a uh consulting firm in 1998
called Medical Technology Partners which
have run continuously since then uh we
are a reimbursement consulting firm so
we get involved with reimbursement
issues Medicare commercial largely
dealing with new technology or services
and um uh you know help the people that
uh you know have come through with with
Innovations understand the healthcare
reimbursement system and how to
integrate those things uh into what
exists um uh so um uh myself and the
people we work with are experts on um
many of the federal fee schedules like
the inpatient payment system Hospital
outpatient physician fee schedules
durable medical equipment Home Services
there's over 20 of them and almost all
of them Medicare tends to be uh the most
expert at uh putting together the the
fee schedule that other uh entities use
as a basis for making payment um uh I
have never as a uh consultant worked uh
as uh on the ambulance particular uh
ambulance fee schedule itself uh but
there there's a lot of similarities in
Crossing between one and another one and
another uh uh there's been several
important developments in the last uh
with the last term uh in response to um
uh the basically bankruptcy and going
out of business of many uh ambulance
services including increase in the
Medicaid rates as part of the budget
last year uh the allowance of direct
payment uh to ambulance providers as
opposed to going to the patient and then
having the ambulance providers having to
try to chase down that money and then um
uh s SP
409 uh which um uh Senator PR Apprentice
championed uh here provides for
insurance payment uh under the Medicaid
Program for non um non-transport type of
services uh in in um in the in the
service uh in Lincoln and Woodstock that
represents 39% of the calls so it's it's
a lower be a lower reimbursement but
it's uh than some of the other services
but it's um more than zero so these
these things we hope are are starting
the process of having a financial model
that actually works enough that
regardless of whether this is a fire
department service a for-profit service
or a nonprofit service uh there's you
know reasonable chance you know with
with um you know not overwhelming
Community Support to allow these to
exist uh ambulances aren't considered an
essential service you don't have to
provide them um but I think we all think
it's a pretty critical ele element of
medical care and uh at a time time of
life when when people need help um so um
I would like to talk about a couple of
the elements that are in this proposal
um uh the the effort towards having
reasonable and fair payment uh from the
insurance companies uh they talk about
an all-payer model all-payer models for
healthcare reimbursement systems are
very unusual meaning that uh all payers
would pay the same amount Maryland does
that for hospitals they're about the
only one that does that um but um uh the
um uh you know in general the much more
common commonly used 99% of the time is
that Medicare serves as a base uh for
for uh establishing other payments and I
do think you know being someone who uh
deals all the time with
Medicare uh and uh that I don't think as
a state either through the insurance
department or through uh Henry litman's
group over in Medicaid services that we
would have much luck influencing how
they're going to change change the
Medicare rate because we have a a law
that says I if if the intent of of this
rule as written uh is to have the fee
schedule amount be the same from all
insurers I don't think that's going to
going to going to fly and I certainly
don't think it's under our control in
the state of New Hampshire um it does
say public and private funding uh would
be the same and I have a question of
what public means because if the if the
public includes money that cities and
towns uh just donate or provide as an
access fee and that's added to whatever
is paid under on a per per uh case basis
for Medicade and Medicare that's that's
a very different math than what um
what those in healthcare insurance
industry view as an allpay model is in
there um so um you know I think the more
workable Solutions are uh to um uh is to
Peg payment to Medicare rates and use
current Medicare rates and and try to
have a reasonable uh markup from that
which um I think would be higher than
the 209% that's in the report um be
um uh the other element to the bill
countering that is this balanced billing
issue um balance balance billing is a
problem uh people who need a ride and uh
you know could could face uh severe
Financial health problems with if they
have a ride that turns out to be very
expensive and Way Beyond their means and
um I previous
been against getting rid of the balance
billing provision because uh there was
no leverage between an ambulance
provider and uh a health insurance
provider particularly those out of state
you know some of some of them would say
our our non-contract rate for an
ambulance ride is
$25 and uh they're in South Carolina and
there's there's they they don't have any
leverage you know people ski ski in New
Hampshire from all over the country
and uh uh uh in addition the ambulance
providers tell me they didn't really
have a lot of Leverage and even
negotiating reasonable contracts uh if
there is a bill passed whether it's this
one or whether this is we reworked or
one of the other uh bills that that U
may come before this committee and one
it being introduced in the Senate um uh
I think I think the uh the that puts
sufficient Leverage in with insurance
companies that we can um uh try to try
to remove this balance billing uh
prohibition uh in ambulances and um you
know I see you there there is there is a
growing base with with the laws passed
last term and um uh you know with
sufficient payment uh from there it's
still still not going to guarantee that
every ambulance service is going to be
viable or or not overwhelmingly in in uh
inexpensive or expensive but um uh uh I
I think it'll be a more traditional
medical service business uh at that
point and um I think we can do both of
these things at the same time provided
the numbers work out so um you know that
is the high level I'm happy to answer
uh I'd like to call up uh commissioner
Court thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee DJ Bon Court commissioner
of the New Hampshire insurance
department I'm joined here at the table
by my colleague Alex Fel Daval I never
get his title exactly right he's our
jack of all trades I'm also joined by
Jason a is the director of our data
analytics unit and of course Jennifer
Smith who does a phenomenal job for us
as well so we are here today in support
of this
legislation it is a proposal brought
forward at the behest of the department
although there's a bit of a caveat to
that in the sense that
we were certainly prompted to do this by
what you all asked us to do last session
I want to start by providing background
for those who are new to this issue or
to those of you who have not followed
every Twist and Turn of this story
consider this a bit like the a big long
pre- preview to your favorite show when
they come back after the previous season
ended they catch you up on things so
that you know what's going to happen as
the new season starts
balance billing and the inability of
carriers and ground ambulance providers
to get into contract or in network has
been a policy challenge facing this
state stretching back 25 years or so
maybe even perhaps longer than that this
department for approximately that same
period of time has taken the position in
its role to protect and advocate for
consumers again has taken in the
position that balance billing a consumer
is the wrong thing to do when I was here
last week for the orientation I provided
you with a little bit of an example of
how balanced billing works I want to
share with you again the example that I
used using very small simple hopefully
easy to understand numbers so you or a
family member needs a ride to the
hospital from an ambul
provider the bill for that ride as
determined by the provider is say
$1,000 your insurance carrier or your
family member's insurance carrier is not
in network with that ground ambulance
provider with the carrier has set as the
rate at which they will reimburse an
outof network provider is say
$200 so the bill is a th000 what the
carrier is going to pay is 200 the
question becomes what happens to the
$800 and what happens at present is the
$800 is passed along to the
consumer now let's be clear the consumer
in the vast majority of instance and we
know this based off of what consumers
are telling our consumer division these
are real people these are real
calls what they tell us is we don't
understand what this bill is for I have
coverage I have health insurance
coverage I don't understand why I'm
getting this bill when I have coverage
and we have to walk them through what's
going
on and over time the real life
consequence has been and again these are
real
stories you have individuals who find
themselves in some sort of an urgent
medical
situation who in the moment they are in
that situation have to pause and
consider whether or not they want to
call 911 to get an ambulance ride to the
hospital or whether or not they're going
to try to call a family member or wait
it out until somebody comes home and
finds them to drive them to the hospital
because they're not sure they can pay
that bill that is
real that is the consumer harm that at
the end of the day my department is
incredibly concerned
about
so at this point I want to pause and
make one of a handful of points very
clear that I will make throughout the
course of this
presentation if in fact you move forward
with this pres with this proposal in a
manner that prohibits balance billing it
does not mean the provider doesn't get
paid in fact it doesn't even necessarily
mean that the provider will not get paid
over and
above what the carrier is willing to pay
an out of network
provider as you've heard before ground
ambulance is the Last Frontier of
medical services that does not prohibit
balance
billing but in all of those other areas
whether it be with the state level
protections or whether it be with the
federal protections through the no
surprises act there is an independent
dispute resolution process that can be
accessed by either party and that
independent resolution process will
determine based off of the facts that
both parties provide what the
commercially reasonable rate should be
for that ride again when there is a
conflict between the provider and the
carrier and the amount that that
independent resolution process May
produce again may be well over and above
whatever that carrier was going to pay
that Provider by virtue of them being
out of network you can do that here if
you'd
want so again fundamentally what we are
seeking to do and what we have advocated
for over many number of years is to
remove the consumer from the dispute
between the provider and the
carrier that's what the state level
balance billing prohibition does that's
what the no surprises act does that
fundamentally is what we are trying to
do here we fundamentally believe that it
is unfair to stick a consumer in the
middle of this dispute and give them a
bill that they didn't know was coming
don't understand and for many of them
they can't
afford so that has been the principle by
which my department has engaged on this
issue in the past let's flash forward to
the summer of
2023 I just become
commissioner I began reading in the
newspaper
stories about ambulance providers who
were under
significant and very real financial
distress and I read those stories and I
want to be very very clear I have
nothing but the utmost respect and
admiration for the work that our ground
ambulance providers provide they have
saved my father's life they have
transported my children and I've got two
boys ages four and seven as boys that
age or want to do they sometimes do
stupid things they bump the head they
got to go to the ambulance I have great
respect and admiration for what they do
I would never report to understand the
full totality of the challenges they
face but I do understand the obligation
that they're under to maintain a
constant state of Readiness whether or
not as representative hunt mentioned
they get a thousand calls in a week or
they get zero calls in a week they've
got to be ready under all circumstances
I understand that and I get
that but I was reading these stories of
the financial troubles they were having
I paired that with the position the
department had taken with respect to
balance billing and I thought to myself
maybe the Stars the Moon and the Sun
have aligned in such a way that we can
bring all of the parties together put
the best ideas on the table and
potentially bring a resolution forward
that does right by the providers that
does right by the communities that does
right by the consumer and so out of that
came the ambulance Summit as I nicknamed
it it was a series of meetings that my
department hosted we brought together a
wide array of stakeholders we obviously
had officials from the Department we had
providers there at the table both
commercial and Municipal providers we
had all of the carriers at the
table we formed subgroups to look at the
different aspects of this
problem whether it was the reimbursement
rates whether it was the challenges that
the providers were having with transport
to uh from from one facility to another
facility to facility
transports and also considering what
reforms the providers needed to consider
in their business model to ensure that
they were financially sustainable and
stable going forward and it was out of
that ambulance Summit that we came to
appreciate that here in New
Hampshire the ride mix
is Approximately
80% of the
rides are from one of the two government
programs Medicare
Medicaid and as you
know the trouble with those two programs
is those reimbursement rates are
fixed Medicare rates are fixed entirely
by the federal government we can
certainly Lobby them representative
spear we can certainly explain to them
what we're doing the situation that we
Face here in New Hampshire and encourage
them to consider rate increases for
Medicare this being the federal
government and I would first start by
engaging the federal delegation who I
think understand this problem very well
and Could Be an Effective advocate for
us but you've also got
Medicaid again
set foundationally by the federal
government the state does have a role in
that you in fact increased at the state
level the reimbursement rates for ground
ambulance in the last budget my
understanding is that was helpful
clearly there's more to be
done
fundamentally the financial crisis as I
understand it that the providers are
facing is there is a Delta between what
they are able to get in
reimbursements from those 80% of rides
from Medicare and
Medicaid and what they need to sustain
and my fear
is what is being attempted here under
the status quo is to fill that
Delta on the backs of the commercial
insurance individuals those who are
covered by an insurance a commercial
insurance
carrier it seems to me as though what
they want what the status quo
dictates is that 20% of those rides will
fill the
delta in the
budgets in terms of what the providers
are not able to collect from the 80% of
the
rise as a personal matter I don't know
that that's fair I don't think that's
fair however as a policy
matter if you do
this if you say we're going to set the
rate at whatever amount it takes to fill
that
Delta there is no
question that you will see an increase
in commercial insurance premiums that's
a policy decision for you to
make but the consequence of that will be
higher
premiums and we talk a lot in this
committee and over in the Senate and
elsewhere about things that are barriers
to access to care for
individuals and there are a number of
things
but for me
fundamentally the biggest barrier to
access to care for residents of this
state is
cost and you cannot lose sight of
that you cannot lose sight of
that and
so we brought the report forward you
have it before you you can take a look
at exactly what we looked into you can
look at
exactly excuse me the conclusions and
recommendations that were brought
forward and that report was the basis
for the discussion that we and others
had with you last year now at that point
in time we were not able to reach a
consensus as to
exactly what the appropriate remedy and
specifically what the appropriate
reimbursement schedule should
be and again we're talking now just
about what the appropriate reimbursement
schedule should be for commercial
insurance
carriers as tied to as Tethered to the
cost to transport commercially insured
individuals and so as a result of the
fact that we were not able to come to a
consensus on
that the legislature asked us to gave us
a
directive to undertake an analysis an
Actuarial analysis
to look at the data to look at the
numbers and determine what the
appropriate rate schedule should
be we as a department were very clear
that level of
analysis was not something that we
internally would be able to undertake
and you know what that was actually very
fortuitous because what it forced us to
do was to take the entire issue out of
our hands and I'll stipulate I'm bias I
want to be done and be rid of balance
billing so I took it out of my
Department's hands and we contracted
with an independent third-party
Actuarial firm no dog in the
hunt to look at the numbers to take in
the data to hear from the stakeholders
and to put forward what they based on
the math determin to be the most
appropriate reimbursement schedule
and they did that and it's important to
note a couple of
things the and by the way that actual
report by PCG is also before you they
engaged in a very inclusive process all
of the stakeholders were brought to the
table they were regular sessions where
everybody came together provided input
got feedback got updates on where they
were in their
analysis but fundamentally the numbers
that piece CG used in their analysis are
the numbers provided to them by the
providers themselves they're not my
numbers they're not the carriers numbers
they're the numbers that the providers
gave to them to Crunch and analyze and
that is what is reflected in the report
and those are the concepts that you see
reflected in The Proposal before you a
few
points PCG the individuals as I
affectionately call them the math
nerds will be available to you what
we're going to do my understanding is
that representative Hunt is going to
consolidate the three propos proposals
coming before this committee pertaining
to this issue into one
subgroup whenever that subgroup is
scheduled to meet the folks from PCG
will fly here to New Hampshire they will
go as deep and as thorough and as wide
on their analysis as you would like them
to go and you can ask them any question
that you would like as to how they
arrived at the conclusions that they did
certainly Alex and I and Dr AES will do
our best as well should you have
questions
today but those individuals will be
scheduled so as I've said the data
before you is the data that was provided
to them by the provid ERS so they'll get
into that as
well I want to also be clear this
legislation does not
dictate that providers and carriers must
get into contract this is still the
United States of America government
cannot force two private parties to
enter into an agreement enter into a
contract if they don't want to if they
can't come to mutually agreeable
terms what we do hope the proposal will
do is to provide an incentive and to
provide a basis a
foundation for those two parties to be
able to have more fruitful
negotiations to be able to come into
Network and there are a lot of
advantages to them coming into Network
there is certainty for the provider as
to what they're going to get from the
carrier hopefully the negotiations
become far less was contentious and
again because of the prohibition on
balance billing the consumer is removed
from
it so that is that is the hope that is
certainly our hope that is the goal of
here I'm going to be candid with
you I've been at this for a long
time I think that what is before you is
the most viable solution to a very very
difficult problem not the perfect
solution and I know that you're going to
hear from a number of providers who are
going to tell you that the rates that
are reflected here are
insufficient I understand
that one of the key questions I think
you have to
consider when some of these providers
tell you that they charge well over and
above the rates that are dictated
or put forward in this proposal is at
the end of the day you can charge
whatever you
charge and I would submit to you and
again they understand the nuances and
the details way better than I and they
may have a
perfectly great answer to this that puts
to rest my confusion on
this but I have to believe that if they
had a high degree of success in
collecting whatever it is they
charge they would not be under the
financial pressure that they're in
there's a problem there I don't know
exactly what it is I suspect a lot of it
has to do with the fact they can build
consumers and balance build them but at
the end of the day if the consumer
cannot afford
it and the consumer doesn't care about
their credit score they just won't pay
it
the provider
out like I said I don't know that that's
the totality of the problem but I know
it's a part of the
problem so as I've said I think what
you've got here is a viable solution
based off of math based off of a fair
and impartial
analysis and it's worthy of your
consideration and the last thing I'll
say is you've kind of
got a limited number of options and this
is a policy decision for you to make so
I'm going to put forward to you what I
think your options are and then you
decide which of these is most palatable
to
you you could continue the status
quo but my understanding if what I have
been told is true and there's absolutely
no reason to believe that what I have
been told is not true if you continue
the status quo you will continue to have
providers who are in financial distress
if they are commercial private ambulance
providers with no back
stop they could potentially go out of
business
altogether if they're a municipal
provider there's a little bit of a back
stop there they can dip into their
underlying fire department budget or
they could pass the cost off to the
property taxpayer not a great solution
not one that they're happy with not one
that I'm happy with probably not one
that you're happy with either we're all
state point being is that not all of the
providers are exactly the same
posture and we of course can continue to
balance Bill consumers and hurt
consumers that's the status
quo you can move forward with this
proposal which to me based off of my
read is the perfect definition of a
compromise in the sense that the
providers aren't happy the carriers are
here I don't know that they're going to
say anything but let me tell you based
on the conversations that I've had they
aren't happy because they're having to
pay more they're having to pay more
particularly for those rides that are in
Rural and super rural areas of our state
where the rides are less frequent but
the distances are longer so they're not
happy and I guess the only person I
guess who's kind of sort of happy is me
because I and maybe you because you get
to put this issue to rest but again when
you're talking about the two parties
that have been most in conflict with
each other over the course of this issue
over those 25 30 years are the carriers
and the
providers but at least under this
proposal you have the
basis for those providers to begin
bringing in more financial support and
at least back some of them away from the
financial cliff that we're told that
they're
facing the third option is you can set
the
rate however you want you want to go
300% 400% over an aade you can do
that again you can't force them into
contract but you can set the
rate way up
there understanding that if that is in
fact what plays out you're going to see
increase in premiums it's going to be
more difficult for individuals to afford
those premiums and while it is never
something that I would recommend there
are a portion of those individuals who
all I wish I had something a fourth
option that brought everybody together
in
celebration I don't have
it and my commitment to you is to always
be honest and so as I survey this
situation as I survey the landscape of
what's before you you those are the
three options that you have to consider
and it's a policy decision for you to
make so at this point I'll turn to Alex
is there anything there that I have
missed that you feel is important for
the committee to uh be aware of no um
you've done a great job of um describing
the landscape and overall policy
considerations but um what I would like
to do would be to go over um
in just the right amount of detail
what's actually in the bill so that we
can have a good common understanding of
what the bill does and uh I've put most
writing so um as briefly as possible
then um this bill uh does three
things uh in essence it requires the
establishment through insurance
department rul making of a cost-based
annually updated rate schedule that
commercial payers will be required to
use in reimbursing ground ambulance
providers who not are not in network
that's number one sort of a mandatory
schedule if you don't have a contract
this is the rate that you will reimburse
at number two it prohibits ground
ambulance providers from balance
billing and number three it establishes
a commission on all pair model program
for ground ambulance services that will
examine the feasibility of applying for
a federal waiver under section 1115a of
the Social Security Act to enter into an
allpay model agreement for reimbursement
of ground ambulance services in the
state
the alpair model agreement would do um
you you've heard some mention of it
already it would create a common
reimbursement schedule for Medicare
Medicaid and Commercial payers it's
something that exists in a number of
other
states um Maryland is is one
example um it requires a waiver and you
have to meet Federal standards it would
mean uh in this case Medicare raising
their rates um as well as Medicare to
come up to this uniform rate
schedule and you have to show that
overall you're going to uh change your
system in such a way that it will be
cost neutral to the federal government
so that's why there's a question about
the feasibility of doing it but um it
would be such a beautiful solution to
this problem that it's worth worth um
analyzing the feasibility of doing it
and that's what this commission is set
up to do as well as to make
recommendations for reform in the
financing and delivery system for ground
ambulance
services um the fee schedule uh this
this bill is a result of last year's
legislation Senate Bill
407 um which required the insurance
department to commission the cost study
um and as the commissioner um mentioned
we um we put out an RFP we got good
responses uh we got four good bids and
we selected PCG because of their
experience advising ground ambulance
providers across the country on how to
fill out the Medicare ground ambulance
cost survey that has been uh in place
the last few years so there's this study
that Medicare is undertaking and
developed a an a very good tool for
determining the costs of ground
ambulance services and PCG was familiar
with
that um the
um Senate Bill
407 put a number of requirements on how
we do this cost study and how our vendor
who we hire does a cost study it has to
be evidence-based so it has to be on
real real information provided by
ambulance ground ambulance providers
about their
costs it the fee schedule they come up
with could be a percenter Medicare or
could be independently developed
schedule um the reimbursement must be
designed to cover their cost now this is
something that came out of the ambulance
Summit that we heard frequently is all
we want is our cost to be covered
because the debate would come up with
you know what ground ambulance providers
really want is to cost shift uh from
Medicare Medicaid onto commercial and
frequently the answer we heard is no we
just want our costs covered so the whole
idea of Center Bill 407 is let's look at
scientifically
evidence-based what a fee schedule would
look like that does cover
the one of the assumptions that was
required to be made in 407 is also that
we hold constant the current level of
funding for ground ambulance that comes
from the local property taxes so in
other words we're not going to try to
replace property taxes with this
reimbursement schedule we're going to
assume that that's just held
constant
um and we're going to uh require that
the fee schedule allow for a reasonable
operating margin for ground ambulance
providers in support of what um is
called Readiness you know uh the ability
to adapt to increases in demand and to
still be able to fulfill uh the services
that are
required um and the cost estimates must
assume services will be provided in a
reasonably cost effective
manner okay so those were are the
injunctions given to PCG in terms of
coming up with a fee
schedule um and
um
the uh New Hampshire insurance
department worked with the New Hampshire
Health Plan and with the Department of
Safety to uh manage the performance of
this project by PCG so we had a work
team a core team that met every week
over the summer and the fall it was
fun was we were under a lot of pressure
um to to get things
done
um the
um process that PCG used was to leverage
the fact that there are these existing
cost surveys that many of the ground
ambulance providers in the state have
already completed under that Medicare
ground ambulance data collection system
called
gats uh at least that's how we all
pronounced it um and uh it's a
well-designed survey it's survey that's
audited and many of the providers are
already completed it so we were able to
leverage those surveys to come up with
sample of uh ground ambulance providers
in the state that did a good job of
representing the ground ambulance
providers as a whole in the state we cut
it up by different categories for
example Fire based not Fire
based Urban rural Hospital based not
Hospital based and in each case from our
sample we had good representation of the
different segments of ground
providers uh so we felt PCG felt that in
the end they had good
representation um in their um sample
that they were using for their analysis
and then they basically
um using the cost information developed
an
overall uh cost per unit of
service uh they broke it down into
transport uh
treat no
transport and mileage so they broke it
out down into those three pieces and
developed and discern the average cost
Statewide for those three pieces of
service and then they built the rate
schedule the Medicare rate schedule I
mean the the rate schedule that's
intended to be cost based using a
Medicare methodology
of once you have a base rate then you
apply relative value conversion factor
that represents the intensity of the
service so there are some procedure
codes that are more intensive in terms
of the level of care providers others
less um so PCG used the
Medicare rvus relative value units to
make those adjustments and then they use
the Medicare adjustments for urban rural
super rural because it provided an extra
boost especially for super rural which
is essentially all of Coos County um uh
they made a couple other assumptions
that were beneficial to the providers in
terms of um treat no transport Medicare
doesn't reimburse at all for
that uh PCC determined that in a cost
based system it made sense that there
would be reimbursement and so they had
to do a separate calculation of the cost
of providing that service and they
included that in the rid schedule and
then they also basically ignored
the component of volunteer work there is
a lot of volunteer support for ground
amulance services in the state but they
basically made the assumption that those
volunteers were getting paid because we
don't know in the future what level of
volunteer effort there will be so they
just added that into the cost
basis and then um having done that they
applied an additional factor which is an
Actuarial
technique
um is called provision for adverse
deviation I like that word we all need
that in our lives um and it means
we may have been wrong circumstances may
be different than we you know determined
through our analysis so they added uh
20% to the rate schedule as a provision
for adverse
deviation um and that's how they came
out with the rate schedule that they did
it
represents 100% increase from what
commercial payers are paying today so
it's
doubling what commercial payers would be
required to
pay from what they're paying
today it represents about 200 something
in excess of 200% of the Medicare rate
so in other words commercial payers we
looked at the claims data they're
currently paying right at or near
Medicare
rates so overall the concept is
there's kind of a deal going on here
we're going to double the rates the
commercial payers pay and in exchange
we're going to get rid of balance
billing and in addition we're going to
form this commission to see about
possibly bringing in Medicare and
Medicaid into this uh overall Fe
thank you Commissioners you're welcome
uh before I open this for questions
remember they are going to a super
subcommittee so try to keep your
questions on point and short thank
you
yes so I watched the whole process it
was pretty
impressive uh
so if we separate out Medicare for a
second because that's still a to-do list
kind of a thing if we just look at the
commercial carrier kind of component of
this thing have you ever gone back to
the uh because the all of the input of
everything came from the
providers that the data that you worked
with so have you gone back to those
providers and said well what do you
think of
this you know get a take on it say um
we did have we
um two advisory groups or um I can't
remember I remember the acronyms are seg
and sag um and there one uh group was
mainly for us to keep everyone up to
date on the progress of the analysis and
then the SAG was actual Advisory Group
where we were asking uh that smaller
group uh that we thought were more
representative of you know opinion of
providers to give us feedback on on the
analysis was that feedback I hate it or
was that feedback
okay um I don't know the the
feedback broadly speaking was always a
bit contingent upon what at the end of
the day the rates were going to be
and I will say too that regardless of
what comes of
this and again this may be Deja Vu for
you it's not going to be Deja Vu for me
unless you drag me back into it I've
done my best here my department has done
my best here as I've said I've put
before you what I think is the most
viable and
fair compromise possible I'm not going
to
keep being Don kyot tilting at these
windmills forever all right but I will
say that if nothing else with this
process was helpful at least to me and I
think to a large degree the carriers as
well was providing insight into what the
actual costs that the providers have to
account for because one of the frequent
pieces of feedback that we would get
from carriers is they would get these
bills for these rides and they wouldn't
understand how they arrived at the
bottom line number what was provided in
the course of that ride sometimes it was
fairly obvious it it was a fairly
intensive
critical Suite of care and services that
were needed but in other
cases they weren't able to really
understand how the dollars added up to
get to that bottom line I think that we
were able to get a glimpse
into what the cost of some of these
various component services are for these
providers and so in that sense it was
very educational
thank you representative Ammon thank you
Mr chair thank you for your testimony uh
it's uh interesting to see this issue
resurfaced time and time again question
about the the actual rate schedule if if
we pass this bill what is the rate
schedule um if you pass the bill then
the insurance commissioner um is
required to promulgate a rule that is um
entally equivalent to the rate schedule
that you see in the PCG report okay and
just a quick followup uh on page two
line
uh it talks about cost
sharing line 18 bill yeah in the bill so
we we're going to prohibit balance
billing but then there's a cost sharing
proponent how does that work is that in
the rate schedule and does the patient
pay that the patient always pays the
cost sharing I think the reference to
the cost sharing in the bill is just to
say uh no balance billing but of course
you are still allowed to charge as a
provider the cost sharing amount that is
in the uh consumer's coverage and so
cier is a broad definition for
deductible
co-pay that's what that references so
despite the prohibition on balanced
billing the consumer is still
responsible for whatever the co-pay is
under their plan whatever the deductible
is under their plan that would not
impact that would not be impacted by
this
term thank uh representative
Gibbs thank you Mr shair and thank you
both um for a very clear explanation of
of how you uh did the work that resulted
in this proposal I do have one question
which I expect the answer yes but I just
wanted to be sure
um does the PCG proposed rate schedule
factor in the costs of the ambulance
providers maintaining constant
Readiness yes that was specifically um
part of what was required in CER Bill
407 from last session um so um that was
talked about and um accounted for in the
race schedule thank
you representative burrow did you have a
question this is a would you believe and
and the other representative uh said
something what I was going to say that
was the commissioner that was one of the
clearest and most concise um
presentations about this issue that I've
ever heard and Alex that was great I
think it could be a major motion picture
at some point so thank you thank you who
would watch it other than
us my wife would watch it keep it short
thank you representative thank you for
letting me ask the question it was very
clear thank you but I just wanted to
make sure I understood maybe a little
bit more on the conclusions so the
information was presented to the
providers and the carriers and was there
subsequent discussion are you allowed to
comment on that
and where where we are kind of right now
between the providers and the carriers
was there any progress made or that's
why we're here today you know as the
commissioner mentioned um virtually all
of the the meetings occurred at a point
where we were just talking about our
process and we didn't have the final
numbers so um we got you know some
response um but most of the
um uh response was held back
until the final numbers was was reached
and that wasn't until very
recently all right think you want add no
I would just say Obviously we worked as
quickly as we possibly could as you may
know we ended up having to ask for a
week's extension we really wanted to
make sure that the
data that we were given and the
conclusions of PCG were making were
Apples to Apples comparisons as best as
possible again the data that was
factored into the analysis was data that
the providers put forward not all of the
providers Gave Over the data in exactly
the same way so we had to figure out
ways to make them as comparable as
possible in some instances that was
easier than in others but throughout the
process we really placed a very heavy
emphasis on fairness and
again nobody's in love with the end
result as I've said by my definition
this is the perfect example of a
compromise nobody's
thrilled each side has been asked to
make sacrifices carriers have to pay
more I think the providers need to
undertake a thorough and thoughtful
consideration of their business model
and make it adjustments to it to make
their operations more financially
sustainable for the long run but as Alex
mentioned even in those areas where we
understood there's going to be variation
there are going to be factors that
cannot be perfectly accounted
for it built in that
buffer to try to account for that in the
political world if I were upholster I
would call it that margin of error if
you will and so we factored that in as
well
representative miles thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking my
question I have a question back to the
phrase uh cost sharing actually um I'm
from a consumer spe perspective I'm
sitting here looking at a pretty average
health insurance card and uh as you
mentioned you know you can see your
co-pay your office visit deductible your
specialist visit deductible for the
consumer is it going to be apparent
somewhere such as their insurance card
what that cost share is for an ambulance
ride or is that going to be somewhere
buried in the plan
documents probably factored into
emergency
service yeah I think you're
right so it's a bit difficult because
it's going to vary from PL plan to plan
so if you're in the individual Market
you have the most control over the type
of plan that you get you go on to The
Exchange number of different carriers
are offering a number of different plans
you're going to have different options
in terms of Networks you're going to
have different options in terms of
deductibles and all of that that'll get
factored in I would say that we would
certainly have a very serious
conversation with the carriers about
making it far more clear to Consumers
what their deductible would be for
ground ambulance rides I was very
briefly whispering to Alex here a second
ago I think it would factor into
whatever the deductible is for emergency
plan thank you Commissioners uh
representative final
question so uh thank you to thanks for
taking a
question has uh this model been uh as of
this particular model no there are
Concepts within this proposal individual
Concepts that have been put in place in
other states this particular model I
don't
believe is yeah implemented exactly in
any other
state there are um about 15 other states
that have tried in some way or another
to deal with uh ambulance ground
ambulance balance billing and to um
address the reimbursement
question uh I would say some of them
have just uh left it up to a dispute
resolution
system and others have thrown a dart in
terms of uh picking um a level of
reimbursement as a percent of Medicare
New Hampshire would be the first state
who actually based it on a cost
study thank
you okay thank you Commissioners thank
you uh commissioner beton Court I would
appreciate if when we go to subcommittee
that could you provide hard copies of
the study I know you have soft copies
but if we could sit there and like make
notes on them yeah I think that we've
got some copies or at least we had some
copies of both the ambulance Summit
report and the PCG report on the back
table we need if we need more we can get
you more long story short we'll have
plenty of copies for all of you by the
time the sub committee work uh rolls
around thank you very much I really
appreciate your testimony today you're
very welcome thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee thank you
uh okay my next
STX I know he's around there he
Commerce I feel like I won the lottery I
got picked right
away it's been an adventure being with
you for many years yes sir thank you I
appreciate
that um for those of you who don't know
me um my name is Chris a was I'm on the
board of directors at the New Hampshire
Ambulance Association and I reside with
my family in Hollis I have been a
nationally registered paramedic in New
Hampshire for the last 40 years and um I
currently am the a Regal director for
American Medical Response which provides
ambulance service for the cities of NASA
and
Manchester uh the New Hampshire
Ambulance Association I want to make
this very clear from the gecko we
support action to Pro protect consumers
from balance billing practices and
regulations that ensure adequate
reimbursement for ambulance ground
providers for the vital Services they
provide we want to take the patient out
of The Middle we've consistently said
that all along that being said um ground
ambulance providers are essential
services and integral parts of the
communities they serve they should be
fairly reimbursed for those Services
Federal lawmakers left ground ambulance
providers out of the NSA as they feared
many of these Services would be reduced
or closed in certain communities due to
the funding challenges and felt they
needed more time to evaluate reasonable
reimbursement
at the same time they recognized that
consumers needed to be protected from
unfair balanced billing practice and
removed from the middle of payment
disputes the federal government actually
put together a federal committee to
study this it came out with a report
which I would be happy to provide to you
and our own uh Senator Apprentice from
New Hampshire was on that
committee the New Hampshire ground
ambulance study committee which was
fully funded by the New Hampshire Health
Plan and its member insurance companies
actually statistically Prov that New
Hampshire's ambulance services are
reimbursed below cost by commercial
insurance providers as well as New
Hampshire Medicaid and Medicare
something we've been saying as many
times as I've been at this
microphone by choosing to continue to
reimburse New Hampshire ambulance
providers below cost the commercial
insurance providers in New Hampshire
continue to force ambulance providers to
balance bill patients so they can
attempt to rec their operating costs we
cannot support 316 in its current form
we believe that the rates recommended
which are actually
197% of the
2025 Medicare rate do not reflect the
impact of the loss of Revenue that New
Hampshire ambulance providers would
experience if they were no longer
allowed to balance
Bill mandating those recommended rates
and prohibiting balance billing would
result in a significant net loss to New
Hampshire ambulance providers and will
put further pressure on an EMS system
already in
crisis desperately what we're trying to
avoid and in direct opposition to what
the ambulance
Summit came up with for its Mission
which was to make this a revenue neutral
process it is not Revenue neutral as put
forward for either
side other parts of the proposed
legislation impose insurance industry
friendly conditions that potentially
reduce reimbursement levels and
potentially tie reimbursement to
continued public fund subsidization I.E
property taxes Things Not Seen in any
other New Hampshire commercial insurance
reimbursement situation that I know
of I also wanted to point out I I
apologize making notes as commissioner
and his staff have been talking there's
a couple of things that I I just have a
couple of questions on there are 11
states that have passed legislation
relative to ambulance billing and almost
all of them are well above the
197% that is being recommended by
PCG uh Arkansas pays at the rate that
the ambulance provider bills that's
selected by the elected officials in the
community where the
ambulance um transport takes place so
does California Colorado pays AT3 25%
Indiana pays at 400% of Medicare
Louisiana at
325 Maine at 180% and I will note that
main just had to come up with $15
million to subsidize the ambulance
providers in the state because their
attempt at balance billing control was a
disaster and that's been talked about in
this committee before Mississippi is at
3 125% Ohio is at
100% Oklahoma Texas and Washington are
all at 325 per. and that was our
recommendation last year when we were
before this
committee I also want to point out that
the advisory groups were not informed of
the result of the study we were kept
well informed about the process of the
study all the way through but the only
way I found out about the study was from
a text from a friend of mine who said
hey it's been released and then I went
and looked at it
and lastly um commercial insurance
providers to the best of my knowledge
are not typically paying Medicare rates
if you recall we passed a bill last year
on direct pay and that direct pay was
the result of insurance providers
sending checks directly to patients when
an outof Network ambulance provider
picked them up and those checks were
very substantial in some cases people
were committing fraud they were so
substantial and they were not at
Medicare rates they were often times at
usual and customary rates I understand
that there may be differences between
Arisa plans and non-erisa plans but I do
not believe in any way shape or form
that the typical commercial insurance
payment is 100% of
Medicare um thank you for your time I'm
happy to uh we want to get to the right
number we want to do this as much as
anybody else does but we don't think and
I'll use commissioner beton Court's um
number that the Delta is anywhere near
number thank you Chris um representative
miles thank
you thank you for taking my
question um can you tell me would balanc
billing enable EMS services to pay more
competitive
wages to paramedics and then if so would
an increase in those wages allow us to
have and provide greater amount of EMS
services to more people of New Hampshire
or
not that's a great question we we our
industry un not unlike health care or
Public Safety is struggling to retain
people that are qualified to provide
services um many of the uh Services
particularly in rural areas right now
have a difficult time attracting staff
if you remove the ability to balance
Bill and don't fill that gap between
what the service is collecting now and
what they will collect in the future you
will significantly impact the ability of
them to continue to provide
services I don't believe that the study
at least I haven't been able to see it
in the study I don't believe that the
study properly account or actually
accounted for that Delta at all it
looked at the cost and I understand that
but it did not look at the cost that
will be lost by not being able to
collect what the insurers are paying now
if they were paying 100% of Medicare as
as um the gentleman from the insurance
commission said I would understand that
are I just wondered if you have any
documentation that you were reading off
of that we could have a copy for
everyone here oh sure absolutely email
yes representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair
um we had a lot of discussion in the
last session about the problem of
insurance company sending the check to
the patient rather than to the ambulance
provider and that this resulted in loss
to the ambulance providers because they
had to track down the patient and the
money and it didn't always come through
and what I'm wondering is does direct
payment provide um an advantage to the
ambulance providers that might at least
somewhat offset the problems that have
been
discussed the financial problems I do
believe that by enacting that law which
we did last year that that has helped
yes well there is there is some
Advantage for direct pay absolutely yes
um you don't have any comparison I'm not
looking for numbers just generalities I
I don't um the organization that I work
for we are in network with the largest
insurance carer so we didn't have that
issue um but and I can't speak for
others that may not be in
all thank you you mentioned 11 states
that are paying doing a better job of
paying the uh providers you guys
yeah do any of those States because I
haven't done that research yet so I want
to do it so but but I want to do it
states are they coming out of is some of
the money coming out of taxes or you
know property tax any kind of tax or is
it all coming from the insurance
companies um my understanding is it's
all coming from the insurance companies
but I be would be happy to provide you
with the documentation it's actually a
white paper so it's got sources for all
the things that are in there so you
could you could take a look at that I I
also understand that um there's going to
be a bill introduced in Massachusetts uh
I Believe by the end of the week that
will be similar to to the one that you
see here in New Hampshire but will be at
won't be 197 it'll be at at um whatever
the community rate is set by the elected
Medicare
okay
59 okay
thank you very much CH thank
you nice to see you again nice to be
seen uh I'm quite sure you'll be here
for the subcommittee also I will do my
best yes and the information that the
representative want is probably going to
be very useful thank you okay uh
reminding my comrades that this is going
to be going to a huge subcommittee so
keep your questions to Point thank you
sitar good morning uh good afternoon
excuse me um my name is Michael sear I'm
the chief of the Tilton offield fire
district today I'm here representing the
New Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs
and to basically speak right now that uh
as the bill stands
currently uh we are opposed to the bill
some of the reasons are that the amount
proposed in the bill for reimbursement
to Providers is substantially lower than
what we need to
survive
the um one of the points that
commissioner talked about was the delta
in regards to Medicare
providers Medicare Medicaid providers
and private insurance providers and uh I
can speak specifically to Tilton not
field fire we have our own Billing
System a formula that was uh approved by
the elected Board of fire Commissioners
and is enacted and the formula is
adjusted every year and through that
formula and through my testimony which
will be shared with you um it'll show
the Delta that of there's a far leftand
Corner that the rates proposed by the
commission and then my rates and then
the far right hand corner shows the
delta in those
not it' be easier to say that the
revenue we collect from billing it goes
to offset the tax
rate if we collect less the tax rate
goes up or we have to reduce Services
that's the basic bottom line of it it's
it's uh not that complicated I have and
if you want I can share how we got our
policy and our formula and we show you
all the math there's nothing hitting
about it as public documents at any
rate
um think something and I'd be happy to
short representative
Sullivan thanks for taking my question
so you said that this wouldn't be a good
enough um reimbursement to be able to
survive that's what you just said right
so you are you do you think you guys
would actually have to close if if this
bill is were to get passed survive is
probably a poor choice of words what
would happen if this bill passes in its
current form is that either we would
reduce our
services or we would have to increase
the uh burden on the taxpayer to
maintain what we currently do okay other
question if you may qu my inquire thank
you um okay
so my understanding is now you guys get
you do the balance billing and you get
the check mailed to you instead of to
the patient because we changed that last
term is that correct that's correct that
was enacted late last year so I haven't
had a full um quite a bit of time to
research how that's affected us but I'm
sure it's a positive so my question then
is um is it possible uh and I know you
don't really know this hasn't happened
yet and it sounds like you don't have a
full understanding of the impact of that
change that we did but is it possible
that this bill would actually like is
there a scenario where you can think of
where you could actually get more money
under this situation versus the current
situation where you have to chase down
insurance companies and or patients to
I'm I I'm going to suggest that it's
going to be have a the bill that
legislation that passed last year with
this direct payment is going to have a
positive effect on our collection rate
um so you think that would be better
than you're assuming the numbers that
we're getting under that old the bill
that we passed last year is going to uh
be better than what we have now that's
the Assumption you're offering you're
operating under I right my assumption is
that our collection rate will be better
being that we don't have to chase down
um instate Insurance private insurance
providers that um don't pay the full
amount um as a side note at Tilton
Northfield fire we have a process if
people can't afford to pay the bill we
have a process where they can be uh go
through to say that you know they're
Indigent or they're poor they just can't
afford it we've never taken anybody to
court and we've never reported anybody
to the uh their credit rating so uh
we're very mindful of that and and I
think we're very careful but it's there
are times where um people have in the
past received checks from insurance
companies and have not forwarded those
payments to us but that has been taken
care of gotcha so but it that's only for
instate providers so if uh I come from
the Lakes Region we're very heavily
tourist business industry we have a a a
bike park where we have nearly 100 runs
a year with people with severe trauma
that we end up bringing to a hospital a
lot of those uh patients are from out of
state and have out of state private
providers
um they would not fall under this
legislation and um but as the
legislation stands we still wouldn't be
able to balance the billum gotcha uh
thank you uh and would you believe it
would be helpful I think if you or
anybody else who's you know another
ambulance organization here maybe when
the subcommittee time comes around it
would be it would be helpful if we had
some insight into the impact of the
changes we made last year and then we
could compare to the potential outcomes
from this potential bill just as we
think through this incredibly
complicated Pro process or problem like
you have sat in this chair a few times
good observation representative very
good
observation thank
you you
question go ahead um so if someone is
hurt up in the Lakes Region and their
insurance is in another state you're not
able to Bill we do send them a bill we
send the bill mainly to the insurance
agent to the insurance company um but if
they're insurance companies from New
York or Connecticut or Massachusetts or
whatever those insurance companies are
follow the laws of that state not the
state of New Hampshire so if we're
certainly out of network provider for
any out ofst State insurance company and
so um they will send us a check or the
the pro patient a check rather than
sending it to us and it's certainly for
a lot less of what than what it
cost thank you very much you're
welcome thank you Michael thank you very
much okay next will be Miss Paula Rogers
good afternoon thank you very much Vice
chairman um for the record my name is
Paula Rogers and I'm here on behalf of
America's health insurance
plans and I just wanted to comment
briefly on the bill and I've listened of
course to the testimony and the
presentation of the Departments and I
can personally attest to the fact that
ambulance bills have been the bane of
everybody's existence
they seem insoluble and we we got we've
gone in circles and we've labored over a
number of sessions about direction of
payment should it go to the member in a
non-contracted situation I mean in a
contracted situation surely in an
uncontracted situation there's no
contract with the uncontracted ambulance
core so we had historically sent the
check to the member the only person with
whom we have a a relationship and of
course that put the providers in this
awkward situation of having to
chase the
money then a bill was passed that said
well plans you can send it in either
direction and finally the most recent
one is send it to the person I mean to
the provider and I am sure that there
has been some benefit to the providers
how large that benefit is I don't know
but it's not going to solve the whole
problem you're working on here when I
heard the department presentation I was
frankly very impressed with the lengths
they went to to get a consultant lined
up the cooperation of the
providers and now we have some results
and ahip as a Association of health
plans we don't wildly Embrace government
rate setting so we're hesitant on that
part of the bill but I have to tell you
in sort of a convenience factor the
study is very informative and very
helpful as a source of data because the
Contracting process is fraught between
plans and providers and the ambulance
providers there's a long history of this
issue and it does have an it has gravity
in almost every state I suspect I was
surprised to hear Mr STW say that there
are 11 states that have some sort of
rate setting
system and representative spear when you
said you were going to do some research
on it so am I because I was aware of
Connecticut and perhaps one other state
but it's interesting and it might be
interesting historically to see what
finally had those States decide we've
got to do something about this I'm not
sure where we are in New Hampshire at
that at this point I'm not with the kind
of knowledge that I would know that the
one thing in the bill 3516 that I wanted
to say that we support is something to
address balance billing and I agree with
the commissioner the patient is is in
the is in the middle on that and uh it's
really very important that we do
something about it I mean I've heard the
Prov the ambulance
providers suggest their reluctance to
sort of embrace that but I think it's
something that the committee can work on
and and see see if there's some
constructive way can we can get over
that hump because there was a hump at
the federal level and that ground
ambulance was not provided by Federal
Protection and when the state's picked
up on it they too have held back on on
uh ambulance provision services so I
just wanted to make those comments but
most of all I know that's it's it's a
it's a Hu you're going to have to have a
very large subcommittee it's a workload
and
it's it's it's it's intensive you're
really going to have to pay attention
because it's it's such a vital issue to
the plans and to the providers
and plans may be reluctant but we need
to be realistic and we need to look at
discussion representor
steer I'm not positive this is a
question or a comment re related to a
question but some of the uh states that
were settled off have state subsidies
for their health
plans and so the question
is and that I want to research and find
out how many of those states are
subsidizing their ambulance plans with
state taxes which is fine I mean they're
certainly welcome to do that and they do
that in a lot of a number of a number of
areas we have to decide if we can afford
that but that's another issue I no I I
think that's an important uh observation
and research needs to be done so I'm all
interested in see how seeing how this
develops quite frankly I hope we get the
list of those 11 states okay thank
you thank you representative Sullivan oh
I'm sorry this I know this thing blocks
I can't see your face um yes the
previous speaker said that we when
somebody from a touristy area which I
represent so it's it's why I'm asking
this question when somebody comes to
these tourist locations and they're
coming from New York or Massachusetts or
wherever out of state then they send the
balance bill or the balance of the bill
to or a the bill whatever they're
sending to the insurance company in that
state and then they're regulated by the
state that they're in so B Massachusetts
New York whatever it might be um I'm
curious maybe you know how it impacts
New Hampshire so if I am insured and I
go get hurt in I don't know the birk
shears and like how when they send their
bill to you guys do you guys just say we
abide by New Hampshire laws and so you
have to pay the balance of the bill or
how does that work well it's going to
vary from company to company but one
thing I will tell you is that when I was
in a company we often struggled with the
issue of well it was a Blue Cross
company so people would say well the C
says Blue Cross on it
and yes but it's Blue Cross of
Connecticut and you're in New Hampshire
so you've got a billing issue you know
in another state and you do have to deal
with the other state there are um
service agencies that can deal in in
basically assisting and I I actually
encountered one I've forgotten where it
was located on the border of
Massachusetts over in the Portsmouth
area where they were doing claims
because there were a lot of crossb
issues and they were basically servicing
the claims and making sure that the
providers who have more things to do
than worry about which ambulance Ser um
which insurer you have to pursue to get
your ambulance claim paid so it's a
complicated matter and I don't think
there's one clear answer to the question
you just
well thank you Paul you thank you next
up uh is
Derek from
hookit the last name alond sir okay
thank you very much thank you uh my name
is Derek amen I am a resident of hooki I
am the current president of the New
Hampshire Ambulance Association and you
know frankly I'm not going to go over
and reiterate that you know the um
testimony from um you know
representative Sullivan chief satar
Chris they was because um the
association
theic
yourdon they have um Chris already
represented the association's position
on this bill I guess from my standpoint
just being a paramedic of 30 something
years longer than I really care to admit
Chris has been longer though just for
the record um the uh I just have wanted
is there any questions for the new
members about the actual you know what
what what it is an ambulance does you
know what it is that happens here in the
state what is different than other
states you know what is the you know
components that maybe some you know a
lot of members here have been in this
group for years and years and years not
me this is only my third time here not
like Chris I was just curious again um
you know this issue was new to me
several years ago when it started you
know the weaponization of reimbursement
that the insurance companies you know
had um initiated quite a long time ago
the problems of reconciling you know
Readiness with you know what that cost
was you know and just the expectation
here in New Hampshire um just so you're
aware when you dial 911 anywhere in New
Hampshire you get the same answering
Point regardless and you know the
expectation that's created by that you
know what is your emergency when they
answer that phone line I was just
curious if I could answer any questions
members great thank
you thank you
uh my final
card on this bill Nathan
Boran from
sir thank you sir my name is Nathan
Borland I am a paramedic currently with
Stuart's ambulance uh I have been in Ems
for about 25 years uh so Chris has me
beat as
well uh I started in the state of
Vermont where I live uh I started in New
Hampshire in 2010 or 11 as a paramedic
um I make the commute down here uh
because it's a better work environment
for me and it fits better with my
schedule uh I have recently obtained my
FPC certified flight paramedic so I am
uh certified Critical Care paramedic
which is the highest level of service
that you can get prehospitally without
me going to PA school or medical school
and I have no intentions of doing that
uh I apologize to you in advance here
speaking to you everybody's touched on
what I had in my head at this point plus
I didn't initially intend to speak to
you today I was coming to listen but I
felt I can offer you a few pieces of
insight that you might not get
elsewhere um so balance billing I think
everybody in this room is an agreement
that balance billing shouldn't happen
we've beat this horse to death for many
years but we don't have a solution for
it because it's a necessary evil to keep
ambulance agencies alive at this point
none of us like to send a bill to that
patient you know when the insurance
company has paid uh you know x amount
when we've build you know y amount and
wait where's this bill coming from uh
personally I ran an agency up north as
far north as you can get in the state
for six years and my practice then was
if someone came to me with any kind of a
hardship whatsoever I worked out payment
plans I helped with hardship cases where
okay we'll just write this off uh my
experiences up there on average every
year we build out about 2.4 million in
services and collected around 900 to a
million back so there's a big disconnect
here in terms of reimbursing and funding
and the difficulty of that becomes who
picks up that extra cost our cost of
service is fixed we have to pay our
people uh whether they're on a call or
not we have to buy this truck whether
it's on a call or not whether the wheels
are turning whether it's parked it
doesn't matter it costs the same so we
have to stay in business in order to be
able to provide this service our costs
are pretty fixed I mean you have some
variability with overtime and you know
pandemics and eclipses and the things
that cause us to have to add staff at
times but for the most part it's
fixed uh so balance billing none of us
want to do at all but we have to at this
point because we have to make up that
Gap anywhere that we can you've talked
about medic care and Medicaid
underfunding those are being addressed
elsewhere we have no control over that
at this point this is one of the many
drops in the bucket that we need to
address if you don't do something to
change the model
soon ambulance agencies are going to
continue to fail you've already had
several gone out that have gone out of
business uh Best Care uh a few years ago
went out of business Franconia Life
Squad has closed doors and is now being
covered by Littleton fire department at
a substantially higher cost by the way
uh like five or six times the cost of
what it cost to maintain frankon Life
Squad um you've seen in the papers
recently Warren Wentworth EMS um
Lynnwood ambulance they're all
struggling financially everybody is if
you don't do something soon this system
is going to continue to fail and then
you're going to dial 911 at some point
and nobody's going to respond and none
of us want that either uh so we need to
do something but what's the answer the
answer is not setting it at you know
196% of Medicare or or whatever this you
know proposal has set out and I'll tell
you why because in reading that study
what when I look through it it said
operating costs plus
2% so that you know we can pad our
budget to survive while in the time
frame since this study was released the
cost of purchasing a brand new Z cardiac
monitor has gone up by 177% not
2% the cost of buying a a truck and in
February of 22 I ordered an ambulance
for the 45th parallel EMS when I was
Chief up there we ordered it and locked
it in
$188,000 when it was delivered to us in
April of 24 the sales guy who's a good
friend of mine said hey are you sure you
want this for this price because I have
somebody that just offered me 250,000
for it cash site on scene and I can get
that easily I'm like nah sorry we have a
contract for 188 this is what it's going
to be so those prices I mean that's a
huge increase from 188 to 240 or 250 all
of these costs keep jumping Higher and
Higher and Higher and what's our annual
inflation at this point where are we
where have we been for the last four
years so from a human aspect me as a
provider with the experience that I have
wanting to be able to help you in your
time of need next year you're going to
give me a 2% raise when inflation is you
know four five 6 8% you're not going to
keep people in this line of work doing
that we're already struggling to keep
people employed I know I'm not going to
get rich doing this job I do this job
because I love it I would just like to
not have to work till noon on the day of
my funeral if that's possible
please um so those are the kinds of
things that we're dealing with um I'll
be happy to answer any questions for you
uh user had a good question for me I'd
like to address uh initially when you
were asking about adest Staters the area
that I covered up north uh was a lot of
Tourism snowmobilers and the like and
the answer to that is you take what you
get and you're expecting that you're
going to have to write the rest of it
off for the most part because you just
have no Avenue to pursue you can call
the insurance companies and try to get
more and you get put on hold for 45
minutes to an hour and then someone
picks up the phone and oh we're
disconnected accidentally so you start
the process over so we never get
anywhere ambulance agencies as your
small you know little either private or
municipal or nonprofit agency do not
have the same bargaining power that a
Nationwide Insurance company does so to
try to litigate and go after we can't
compete with their lawyers it's not
possible therefore you take what they
give you and either the taxpayer picks
up the bill or you write it off and you
know as as the chief said you're faced
with do we go to the taxpayers for more
money or do we cut Services uh and I can
tell you that a lot of your rural areas
especially the further North you go the
worse it gets they're already paying
exorbitant property taxes to maintain
your
services so do you want to save you know
a couple of dollars in premium on a
healthare plan or do you want to pay an
extra $5,000 a year in property tax on
your house that you own that's the
question you're going to have to address
and it does need to be fixed and fixed
relatively
quickly so I will certainly take any
questions that you have uh and again I
apologize for kind of being off the cuff
today thank you um representative Gibbs
remember with this is still going to
subcommittee representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in and representing um
providing us with your information
um the discussion of the PCG report
stated that the proposed rate would be
about double or several people have said
197% of the current in rate of insurance
payment um one of the earlier
representatives of the providers stated
that several other states have enacted
rate schedules that provide for three
325 per of Medicare do you have an idea
of what rate level
would make make it possible for
ambulance services to continue um in a
sustainable Financial
way I can't speak for any of the other
services but last year when we were
talking about this and Senator
Apprentice had the bill for 325 per of
Medicare I went back to my office in
colbrook and I analyzed those numbers
and realized that that was feasible for
us at that time uh I would have to look
at it again I've been out of that office
now for for about 6 months uh I'd have
to look at it again to make sure but at
that time looking at the numbers 325 of
Medicare was going to be sustainable for
us so if the rate set by the commission
was 325 per of Medicare rather than 197%
of current insurance rates um you think
that that would be sustainable for your
organization for the numbers I look at
at the time absolutely that would have
representative miles thank you thank you
for coming um I just want to try to put
this in perspective a bit so I'm going
to use the reference the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs passed out so
the proposed
rate would be for ALS life support
emergency run it says
$1,105 I I know you don't have a stack
of papers in front of you so I don't
expect exact numbers so 11 $100 if you
were to go to your ambulance run sheet
your electronic run sheet check off one
of everything maybe two two liters of
saline two vials of this two vials of
that your gloves your compression bands
for your automated compression device
one of
everything wouldn't that be more than
$1,100 that is the bane of the existence
of ambulance billing right there uh
years and years ago we used to be able
to build itemized billing based on what
we used used we are now lumped into
these you know als1 als2 BLS rates that
if you provide this level of service
it's x amount of dollars the problem
with that is an als1 call could simply
be you needed a cardiac Monitor and I
started an IV on you and so here's you
know $1,100 for this service but that
same ALS billing rate um years ago when
it first came out am odone was around uh
if I remember right $300 a milligram
so it was an expensive drug and we're
getting the same 1,00 bucks for that you
know administering that drug it's come
down in price recently but I mean there
are meds out there that are ungodly
expensive and we get the same
reimbursement no matter what so yes
that's a very valid point thank you
appreciate
that okay representative last question
so uh well thanks for a question taking
my question I I I just want to know that
in the current system where you have
balance
billing are you not getting paid most of
the time or are you getting paid by the
consumer at this moment it varies a lot
depending on the person that you're
dealing with the insurance company that
you're dealing with um the re my
personal experience with getting
reimbursement from balance billing
patients was about 40% collection rate
uh it varies from service to service and
area to area some people that don't care
about their credit rating at all they
just throw the bill away and that's the
end of it other people I I had one young
gentleman that wrecked a snowmobile in
2015 and sent me $5 a week for about 12
years to pay his bill off so there's so
much variability there I can't give you
a solid answer so just just to follow up
so the current system of balance Bing is
not solving your financial problem is it
correct no but if you take it away from
us without fixing everything else it's
going to worsen things
thank
you thank you uh seeing I have no more
cards this hearing is adjourned until
the subcommittee and we'll take a two or
three minute break so chairman hunt can
e
okay let's uh get through this final
bill
here uh House Bill
actually just take a seat over here I
need someone to introduce the bill
because I don't see representative
here all right I won't bother no problem
uh you ready okay Chris you're the only
one has a card in so tell us why you
want this
bill tell us what's better about this
bill well in in um thank you for the
opportunity to speak I won't repeat
everything I said already uh this bill
as I understand it um looks at paying or
compelling the insurance carriers to pay
at whatever rate the community sets so
if you're in chrisville and all the
Selectmen get together and say we think
our cost is $1,000 for an ambulance ride
that's what they set the rate at that's
the amount that this bill would require
the commercial insurance carriers to pay
so short of a percentage of Medicare we
believe that that's a a very good idea
that being said there's a number of
things in the bill that I don't think
are clear and would have to be cleared
up prior to the bill moving forward um
and I will Echo what the insurance
department came up with for their
concerns with in the lot part or the
analysis of the bill there's a lot of
things that just are not spelled out so
the concept of the bill is great but we
can't support it as it's currently
written no this one you say you like
this is 185 correct yeah we say we say
we like it because the theory behind it
is that it compels the insurers to pay
at whatever rate the elected officials
in the community the service I see Bill
at all I think you got the wrong
Bill Insurance should provide
reimbursement rates negotiate between
the insurer and the the ambulance
service provider yep in the absence of
the agreed rate an insurer shall pay the
amount build by the ambulance service
service right oh this is oh this is any
willing provider right so that that that
that the insurance insurance company has
to pay whatever you Bill them correct
yeah what's that got to do with the
local people that that part about you
said had something to do with local but
but because the way the process works is
localities set those rates
what what your community charges for an
ambulance and what my community charges
for an ambulance are not the same thing
our costs are different right so this
bill would
require the insurers to pay whatever
that amount was whatever you determined
it cost you this thing about the local
people being involved but I I didn't
understand sorry you you were not saying
that the my selectman will set the rate
well
that's is that it's the yeah
so whatever you got built yes any
willing provider correct that's all I
you uh any questions from the committee
members who okay we're done is there
anybody else who would like to testify
185 I think everybody's exhausted on
the issue okay so uh for the committee
members I have scheduled next
week um what we have is um we're going
to meet we will not meet Tuesday Tuesday
is free Wednesday uh we will do a
subcommittee on the on the um liquor
bills be Tuesday uh Wednesday morning
excuse me then Wednesday
afternoon um yeah no that's not that's
not the okay let me pull up my cheat
sheet here there we go okay and my my
cheat no that's all we have this micro
bills this is my cheat Chek okay so so
we will do um on
Thursday uh afternoon Thursday morning
we'll do the business Bill we have uh
hearings so Wednesday
afternoon um we'll do the business the
business bills that we did
um would did
today so we will be doing the bills we
heard this morning will be subcommitte
on next Wednesday
afternoon and the bills and and then
Thursday we'll have new hearings we have
a new new uh Billy wax of bills am and
and so it starts at 10:00
a.m. and and these the business bill are
all over the map we
got um that's the afternoon and then in
the afternoon we're going to do some
insurance
bills and they're also um these are
these are not particularly Insurance
bills are health insurance they're all
three health insurance related and
that'll be Thursday afternoon so these
are the morning that's the afternoon for
Thursday th and then then Wednesday
morning we will do the liquor the
subcommittee on liquor bill
and then afternoon and then in the
bills so technically technically just so
you know what the deal is yeah is um
science and technology is supposed to
meet Monday Tuesdays and we get
Wednesday
Thursdays Thursdays obviously is
problematic because we could have
sessions so and and and I will be damned
if I'm going to come in on Fridays no
okay so um the idea is that we will do I
try to do Tuesdays when I can but we
ended up in that committee room down the
you know down
the that's why we're
we technically is Thursday
we're
right
right have session till the end of
it's you know it's just a push to get
through the bills you know we just got
to
get what's that do whatever I say that's
true the good the good you know in this
case like for me like Tuesday you say
well why weren't we doing Tuesday well
on Tuesday I I I'm going to be in
Pittsburgh pennia doing a a board
meeting of my real estate Development
coming oh yeah four times a year yeah so
so I so they're just fortuitously Monday
was a holiday so I
yeah wedn Tuesday Wednesday Thursday is
way always think that we're we're going
to be here and then you and just so you
know on Monday mornings I do I'm
counting County budget so I get but that
that lasts just into February and then
I'm all done with that we'll get our
budget Mondays or Friday we uh Mondays
or Fridays are always free is over yeah
no two to me it was 3 days a week
Thursday if you would like to be sure to
email me so I make sure I got but I'm
pretty sure I kept everybody in the you
have
uh let
see um I guess we have it's a little
lighter this year but um yeah because we
got rid of the fun and we got yeah that
that was good in manufacturing that's
probably good for eight or 10 bills you
know yeah at least uh okay so currently
bills in the committee is 31 wow wow
what we get but that but when according
to Paul
Smith yesterday he still had 200 bills
so we could if we get you
know
so yeah and then and I always say we're
usually around 50 hous and and 25 Senate